e
okay uh we're going to open up the
public hearing for the house election
law committee um we're going to start
with CA CR2 uh relating to the drawing
of District boundaries providing that no
District boundaries shall be uh drawn in
any way that favors or disfavors any
political party candidate um before we
start off uh today's this is school
vacation week There's No votes today um
there's 16 17 bills um so normally we
have a two-minute rule with 5minute
roduction um I'm going to wave that rule
um provided we stay on time if we start
getting off of schedule I'll I'll kick
it back on um so I'm basically going to
make a judgment call based on how many
bills how many how many uh Pink cards we
have and where we are on the calendar so
nor for those of you here normally we're
here normally get to today you can go
we've got an hour for these first two
redistricting bills um so I don't I
don't it's okay if cacr 2 bleeds into HB
363 because I imagine the same people
are going to want to talk um but anyway
so that's where we're going to be today
um like I said if we get behind I'll
kick the rule on um if we don't if we're
doing just fine then we won't with that
um we're going to recognize
representative Howard for the purpose of
introduction thank you honorable Mr
chair and uh honorable committee members
uh my name is representative Heath
Howard I represent the towns of straford
and barington and straford District 4 uh
and today I'm going to be introducing uh
cacr 2 this constitutional amendment is
all about the ability uh removing the
ability to create partisan political
maps both the Republican and Democratic
parties have used Jerry Mander political
maps to make it easier for them to gain
a majority or limit their political
opponents by limiting the use of certain
data like voter records party
registration uh residency information or
any other proxy uh of that information
information during the redistricting
process we remove the politicization of
the maps politics should be left to the
candidates and the people not datadriven
maps which help create predetermined
outcomes drawing Fair Maps doesn't just
make more competitive elections but more
transparent a more transparent
government and responsive government the
highly partisan districts created by
Jerry mandering often see lower voter
turnout fueled by uh perceived IL
legitimacy or diluted
representation these districts also
encourage extremism in gridlock through
the election of polarizing ideological
candidates and the placement of their of
their parties over their
constituencies we need politicians that
listen to their constituents first not
extremists being dictated by their party
and by passing cacr 2 we can guarantee
fairness in the redistricting process
provide more competitive maps and better
representation for the people of New
Hampshire thank you and open any
questions are there questions from the
committee I'll ask represent of Lane I
almost called you Connie my apologies
it's okay I've been called a lot worse
so
[Music]
um when are are you aware of the
redistricting that occurred in
2021 yes okay okay may I have a followup
yes um are were you aware that 7 four
towns voted warrant articles in favor of
this type of a proposition I was not
okay thank you thank you further
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you uh next
up is Bob
Perry from
straford and no proxy today Mr per it's
you Perry is that written testimony yes
can you put that on the desk in front of
us thank
you right right up here yep we have a we
have a you haven't been you've been
missing for a little no right where we
are right now yeah we do written
testimony there and then members can
grab it on the way out that way you
Madness uh Mr chairman and members of
the committee I speak enthusiastically
in support of cacr
2 I am not an attorney though I was
surrounded by them during my 30 years at
the superior court and I saw firsthand
the personal commitment of judges to do
their best through
research I type scores of their
rulings I am not a legal researcher
either so any mistakes spoken here are
unintentional my research has allowed me
to conclude clude that a legal pattern
has been established on the issue of
gerrymandering that court rulings turn
on whether there is a specific
prohibition against Jerry mandering in
the respective state constitutions or
alternatively whether there is specific
language requiring neutrality in
designing
maps without such specificity courts
have determined that the issue at hand
is
non-justiciable on that point a New
Hampshire judge in brown V Secretary of
State rejected claims that partisan
Jerry Ming uh violated part one article
11 of the New Hampshire
Constitution indicating that its issue
at hand was non-justiciable because in
its opinion our constitution does not
provide enough specificity to act the
case was dismissed on appeal by the New
Hampshire Superior Court in November of
New Hampshire is not alone in that
regard legislator Nationwide are
reacting to these suits by updating
their
constitutions and I cite with a link the
New Hampshire example
below Florida New York and Ohio their
Supreme Courts have ruled favorably on
specific constitutional language similar
to the language in this cacr with
variations of quote may not be drawn to
favor or disfavor and an incumbent or
political party end
quote the language in cacr 2 puts a f a
it it is very specific no redistricting
plan and it uses the word
shall which has a specific meaning in
law I am confident cacr 2 provides our
court with sufficient guidance to
prohibit REM mandering in our state I
have provided other examples on a
separate page of the legal pattern that
I see uh has developed though there are
many others attached are examples from
the states of Alaska Pennsylvania and
Florida uh with the North Carolina
example and apparent victim of politics
with its initial ruling reversed at your
request I can provide much more of my uh
detailed research amending our
constitution is doable
it is a matter of will as a living
document it has already been amended 27
times whether to add or remove content
since its Inception in
1784 it was amended as recently as 2018
at part one article 8 I quote from the
Pennsylvania Court quote it is a core
principle of our form of government that
the voters should choose their
representatives not the other the way
around end quote I urge this body uh to
vote OTP thank you thank you will you be
taking questions from the committee Mr
Perry I will are there questions from
the committee saying none thank you next
up is Liz tantarelli um and then on Deck
Andrews but anyway here we are Norm
about cacs
primarily because when the question
appears on the ballot often the public
doesn't understand the wording and
that's because it must be written in
legal ease and it's not always clear
what is added and what is not but I have
no reservations whatsoever about this
particular
cacr because the wording is so clear in
terms of what we're trying to add to the
Constitution and we know that many of
people many people have spoken in favor
of this from both
parties um my testimony here is
addressed both to the cacr and to
36063 when I talk about uh Fair
maps and The crucial role that they play
in subsequent
legislation neither bill says the
obvious whichever party is dominant at
the time of
redistricting will attempt partisan
redistricting to their own
advantage and we've seen it happen in
other states we've seen it here in New
Hampshire no party is above the
temptation to make the next election
easier for their own candidates so the
graphic that is page two of this
testimony um is from uh 2022 but it
makes the point that the swing is back
and forth between and this is a nation
wide statistic this is not a New
Hampshire graphic um it makes this point
visually you know that partisan attempts
swing back and forth so members of both
parties should be concerned about
this um it's true that partisan leanings
happen almost naturally in some towns
and you move to a town you suddenly
realize you're surrounded by members of
one particular party that that town
always votes that way that's that's a
natural phenomenon and it changes over
time often uh but it should not be part
and should not be considered in
redistricting so my ask here is very
simple use your ethical standards to say
that Maps should be fair do the right
thing recommend this bill now so that
when we get to 2030 for the next
redistricting we'll be able to do it
without partisan consideration
and the voters deserve that but also
your party whichever party it is
deserves that as well we have no idea
which party might be dominant in
2030 and we want to make sure that that
process is fair to both parties I'm
happy to take questions if there are any
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you next up is David Andrews and
on Deck is marger Porter honorable Mar
Porter
thank you Mr chairman
um my name is David Andrews I was a data
analyst at the registering data Hub
during the 2020 registrating cycle which
is a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization um I was the lead mapper
for the mapathon project right here in
New
Hampshire um and now I'm just here as a
redistricting nerd um but looking at
these Maps now that we've had kind of
two elections on them I think it's very
clear that you can see that there is a
partisan bias Within These Maps um you
look at the state senate the efficiency
Gap is around 15% meaning that
um the Republican Party win about 15%
more districts than they kind of would
on a a fair map and it's even worse in
the executive Council map where the
efficiency Gap is about
26%
um this
cacr would help um I think both in the
registering process by not allowing um
you know the data to be used um to draw
the maps um
and in the judicial process of reviewing
these maps and um determining you know
whether they can set a standard of fair
Maps or not um and so I strongly um
testify in favor of this I think it's
important to note a few things in the
bill um for instance the um it prohibits
measures of data to be used in the
creation of the map but not the uh analy
of the map which is important because I
think you know myself or I'm sure
representative Barry could draw uh Jerry
mandard map just based on our knowledge
of voting patterns in the towns we
wouldn't need the data per se to do that
um but we could then use the data to
analyze the maps and show you know
efficiency gaps and partisan bias and
all the other uh parameters that are
used in judging whether maps are fair in
uh redistricting um another other thing
that I think is important to note is the
um the segment that says the res
residency of the incumbents is important
um that it won't take that into account
because you know I think in the 2020
registering process it was very clear in
the Senate it was spoken openly that
they were taking into account incumbents
and where they lived into their
registering process Senate District Four
is not Senator Waters Senate District
Six is not Senator Grace they are the
districts they are the people's
districts they are just in those seats
um so we should not be drawing districts
to um you know favor any incumbent or
any other potential
candidates um so I just wanted to say uh
that I am uh strongly in favor of the
CCR let's leave this up to the voters of
New Hampshire to decide whether we
should have you know Fair Maps or not
I'm happy to take questions are there
questions from the committee
representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um in reading this
the two sentences that are added the
second sentence tells you not to use any
any kind of known data to uh accomplish
the
first uh sentence so how do we how do we
get a district that every time you then
go back and look at to see if it is
reasonable measuring the data you have
to throw it out and start over again
yeah so um I drew a lot of maps in the
2020 resing process as part of the
mapathon
um one and this happened to me I would
use um you know communities of Interest
we decided on um using like uh shared
Water Systems um shared police and fire
departments uh High School saus to try
to keep districts together and so I
would use those data I had like
overlapping maps and I would use that
data and then I would go back at the end
of it and I would check to see what the
efficient Gap was what um you know the
partisan bias was so that I wasn't using
the data in the mapping process but I
went back and checked and in one case I
had you know unknowingly created a map
where it had uh partisan bias towards
one of the parties and so I was like all
right let's not use that one and so
there's you know an infinite amount of
possible ways to to draw these Maps so
you just have to you know go through the
process use those um communities of
Interest or whatever is the defining
characteristic and then go back and you
can check further question of the
committee representative um qua I don't
your thank you Mr chairman you mentioned
communities of Interest how is a
political party not a community of
interest and why should it be treated
differently from any other community of
Interest mhm well I think that uh you
can treat it as a community of interest
if you want to but if you were to do
that it would not really be a kind of
gerrymander map in the sense that um
packing and cracking if you were trying
to keep you know Republicans together or
Democrats together you would you could
do that but then it would honestly lead
to a a a fairish map because in the
process of gerrymandering you need to
pack um you know pack a certain party
into some districts and then crack them
in other districts so that you have um
an unfair balance between the two so if
you did treat them as communities of
Interest it would naturally um come out
to be a more fair
map yeah you got follow up yeah follow
up so you're saying that um political
parties as treated as communities of
Interest could result in a fair map yeah
you could yeah yeah am I correct in
reading this amendment that it would
however prohibit that practice um of
using a political party is a community
of interest for drawing AAP it's using
it's it's prohibiting the the data to be
used um for
that further questions um I have one oh
actually represent some you good to go
thank you um when you say the community
of Interest could create a fair map do
you mean if it's used consistently for
both parties yes thank
you further questions um so my question
is you talked about the efficiency Gap
what is the efficiency gap on our
current Congressional Maps where 47% of
the people have been represented 0% of
the time uh I think it's
a it's about so efficiency Gap is using
um um you know
unused so I think it's probably I'm not
I'm not sure honestly it'd be hard to
use a ficient gap on a two District um
map in any way
qua thank you Mr
chairman do you believe that an elected
representative who's affiliated with one
party cannot fairly represent
individuals who are affiliated or
sympathies lie with a different
political party
I would not be able to answer that
as further questions representative Lane
um I don't have a question but um I
understand that the efficiency gap for
congressional districts is different
than for legislative districts um
federally you have to have uh less than
1% is the for congressional districts
and uh for legislative districts it's
less than 10% so Federal Law requires it
to be 5050 in Congress by
population um yes and it's not it's uh
we're off topic here but it's um it's
not 1% it's actually perfectly divisible
you have to get to closest to zero as
possible is actually the standard which
is hard to do in New Hampshire when you
can't use census blocks um anyways any
other questions as we oine and relive
The Glory Days of 2021 um seeing none
thank you uh next up margerie Porter
honorable marger Porter excuse me and
esto thank you Mr chair and you can
leave the Hun part off of my name next
time okay um thank you Mr chair and for
uh members of the committee uh my name
is marjerie Porter I live in Hillsboro
and I'm here today representing the
delegates of the New Hampshire together
citizens assembly which was held in June
and last last time I was here I gave you
an overview of how that process worked
but a short version is we gathered
together 50 people from around the state
that were demographically um the same as
the state and we asked them they were
asked to address the problems of lack of
confidence in elections increasing
polarization and lack of responsiveness
of government to the people they
represent and we asked them to find
solutions they thought were common
ground and everyone could agree with one
of the solutions to the problems of
polarization and responsiveness of
government was the establishment of an
independent redistricting commission to
keep that process nonpartisan and fair
87% of the delegates at that convention
supported this solution we support cacr
2 because we believe it is one step
toward making redistricting fair and
nonpartisan and yes I will take
questions if you have them other
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you uh next up is Linda Bundy and
oh I'm sorry uh Kaylee stadio and then
on Deck is Linda bunny I got my cards
mixed
up um good morning thank you chairman
Barry and the rest of the election law
committee my name is Kaye of stadio I'm
a Durham voter and public policy fellow
with open democracy we're a nonpartisan
nonprofit represent in 36,000 voters
across the state and our mission to
strengthen democracy specifically
through promoting campaign Finance
reform Fair districting initiatives and
transparent elections I'm submitting
testimony today in support of cacr 2 the
efficiency gap which measures the extent
of partisan Jerry mandering is nearly
15% for the Senate 25% for the executive
Council and 7% for the house while the
house seems lower certain individual
districts reach nearly 50% efficiency
gaps in favor of of Republicans these
totals especially for the Senate were
bad enough to Warrant the Princeton
Jerry mandering project to give New
Hampshire a letter grade of f the
packing cracking and general biases
present in redistrict redistricting
practices have led towns with virtually
nothing in common to find themselves in
the same districts this has been the
case in Senate District 9 where the
towns of Hinsdale and benf Bedford have
found themselves lumped together after
redistricting in 2022 despite being 50
mil apart in over an hour and a half
drive from one another local leaders and
residents from both towns said the new
district has made no sense is unfair to
hensdale Residents and dilutes the
voices of people who live in a part of
the state where many already feel
overlooked property values in hensdale
are also amongst the lowest in the state
while Bedford is among the
highest article 11 of the New Hampshire
Constitution says that quote when the
population of any town or Ward according
to the last federal census is within a
reasonable deviation from the ideal
population for one or more
representative seats the town W shall
have its own District of one or more
representative seats end quote this
issue was raised during the 2022 New
Hampshire Supreme Court case of Dober V
scandin because the State House redistri
redistricting plan failed to give a
representative to Dober Ward 4 despite
it exceeding the ideal population and
titling it to one the court saw the
issue of partisan Jerry mandering as
non-justiciable deferring it to the
legislature for remedy in considering
cacr 2 today this committee stands the
chance to make bipartisan history
through enacting desperately needed
redistricting
reform high levels of partisan
gerrymandering have also resulted in the
current 4 to1 split in the executive
Council which does not proportionately
represent the true bipartisan makeup of
New Hampshire additionally article 11 of
the State Constitution requires that
quote in forming the districts the
boundaries of towns Wards and
unincorporated places shall be preserved
and contiguous end quote according to
the citizen mapping Project New
Hampshire mapathon the current house map
contains 62 constitutional violations of
this manner I urge you to consider the
importance of Integrity in constructing
District maps and vote ought to pass on
cacr 2 in order to rectify the issue of
partisan Jerry mandering and I'll take
questions if there are any other
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um ly
uh Olivia zinc will be reading a
statement by Phil Hatcher did I get that
right oh I actually have both Linda and
that's probably why I put those cards
next to each other it's like I planned
it like that for the record good morning
for the record my name is Olivia zinc um
executive director of open democracy and
today I'm I'm just um uh reading for two
citizens so the first is from Linda
Bundy of antrum who supports cacr 2 the
New Hampshire Constitution tasks the
House of Representative that's all of of
you um with making a portion M of
represent
Representatives um therefore creating
vot voting districts after each federal
census however it does not specifically
address the redistricting process
resulting in boundaries that favor one
party over another our executive Council
and state senate maps are the most
erroneous examples of
partisanship by prohibiting District
boundaries to be drawn in a way that
favors or disfavor
any political party or candidate cacr 2
establishes a process that values
fairness over political maneuvering
disallowing partisan data um for
creating districts um sets a clear
standard neither party should be able to
give themselves any advantage cacr
addresses this Fair Maps will be ensured
um that every person's vote matters and
she urges you all to pass on cacr 2 do
you to just go directly to Phil fired
off okay um so Phil Hatcher um also
supports cacr to Phil is from Dover um
Phil uh insert inserting this into the
Constitution as a goal um for the
district maps not to be drawn in a way
that favors or disfavors any party
political party dis um disregarding
concerns of the Supreme Court rule
ruling I'm just going to summarize some
of Phil says a lot so I urge you to read
what Phil writes um although Phil is
urging you to pass ought to pass the
acr2 he has some ideas to make it better
so Phil suggests on page on on line 16
of page
one um that you could remove the word
candidates candidates are voters so he
believes that um the intent um of using
the information of the party affiliation
of candidates um is is irrelevant there
um Phil also uh asserts that Artic part
part two article 11 um is one place but
he also recommends that this be in also
inserted into article 26 and article 65
so that it's not just in the house Maps
it's in the Senate maps and the
executive Council Maps um so that it's
um in multiple places in the New
Hampshire Constitution and he also says
maybe we should use partisan Jerry
Mander uh partisan data for
Congressional Maps either um so he's
sort of saying be inclusive of all the
maps not just the house Maps um and then
he also makes the point which I think
you've heard today about the Dover case
and keeping towns together um and so he
has um some other language um in article
11 um within reasonable deviation from
the ideal population Phil Phil thinks
that this could be better said if you
insert language of each town or Ward
having enough
inhabitants um to The
Entity or one or more representative
seats so to to clarify what what the
legislative intent on that article 11 um
and then one more um minor issue that
Phil has is also in the second sentence
of article 11 requiring each town or W
to be included in one in a non laral
District um Phil thinks that he would
recommend the second sentence saying the
number of eligible Town WS should be
denied on um should be uh minimized so
he thinks you should use minim
minimization instead of float Arial so
those are Phil's ideas to strengthen
this bill um but does support it as it
is if if there is no Amendment and I
have written testimony for both um and
then I also just want to add quickly um
uh in the question that representative
Lang asked um deviation is different
than effic efficiency Gap so deviation
is how is the metric where we measure
what the population increases efficiency
Gap is just another tool to measure
partisan data um but deviation is a
slightly different um term of
Art and I'm with that I'm happy to take
questions are there questions um I so
this would only apply to the state
representative Maps
um the way Phil reads this is it is only
inter um it's only inserting this into
article 11 and article 11 is the house
Maps is the House of Representative Maps
so that's why he's suggesting you also
insert it into
article uh now I'm look I think he said
26 and and 65 which are the other maps
in the state so um because the
Constitution has different articles for
each branch of government
okay and any other questions so my
follow would
be uh what was the efficiency gap for
the house map since this is what it's uh
going
after um I I think it depends on each
district some districts are upwards of
50% and some have lower efficiency gaps
so it depends on um I think there's what
districts uh separate districts and so
it's it's it's wildly dependent based on
which district you're looking at got it
but isn't it also true that the house
map out of all the maps the State House
map most closely reflected the Statewide
popular vote correct okay guess which
one I had the biggest hand in
representative Lane it was that one it
was that I thought I thought you drew
the all the demonizing the map that I
worked the most on was apparently the
most Fair um but didn't you draw the
Congressional map that got veto too uh
no not not exclusively unfortunately
I wish I had
um the uh to be fair uh just you know my
my map actually never made it to the
governor's desk my my map got over ended
in the Senate um next up last up is
stro thank you chairman Barry um this
testimony is on behalf of Leonard
Campbell of Meredith New Hampshire he
also supports cacr to and he says
honorable Representatives voting as the
Lynch pin of any sound Society have a
just and Equitable system having a just
and Equitable system ensures that the
voting reflects the will of the people
at a time when divisiveness and Rancor
make legislating more difficult cacr 2
will aspire to A system that does
reflect the will of the people as in
effect it will remind us that stranded
tiny pockets of Voters are not
marginalized this is a common sense res
resolution the only opposition will come
from those who perceive a benefit for
having lines drawn to support a
particular political party please
support this resolution for the respect
for the New Hampshire Constitution and
he inserted a quote it says all
government of right originates from the
people is founded in consent and
instituted for the general good thank
you okay will you be taking questions
you just reading the statement and
running I'll just read it R I respect it
all right I don't have any more pink
cards and my computer's freezing which I
don't know why it's doing that um online
it was very lopsided and I don't know I
apologize for not having it up already I
did already read it for myself but not
for everybody else uh election
law cacr 2 um online was 353 in support
six oppos zero neutral and with that we
will close the public hearing on cacr 2
and we will open the public hearing on
House Bill 363 establishing
redistricting criteria and we will
recognize our own representative Lane
for the purpose of introduction who will
very kindly get me a pink card uh oh has
one already ready to go awesome I wasn't
fast enough all right representative
Lane uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee um for the record I'm
representative Connie Lane mayor M
district 16 which is W two and conquered
um I brought this bill because um as as
many of you know I keep bringing uh
independent redistricting bills and they
keep uh failing so this is an attempt to
try another way that might be a little
easier uh than doing an amendment to uh
or a statute to set up an independent
redistricting committee not that I'm
giving up on that idea but um this Bill
implements criteria that need to be
followed when redistricting occurs and
it will make redistricting districts the
process more fair and more transparent
uh right now our legislature has almost
no criteria that it needs to follow when
redistricting which is why we've ended
up with the districts that uh we have uh
that have been referenced in the
testimony for cacr 2 it uh redistricting
must follow the US Constitution the New
Hampshire Constitution federal laws and
state laws and this bill adds additional
criteria that have become considered
traditional districting principles and
some emerging criteria that have been
used by other states
increasingly so what is required now
constitutional districts must be as
equal in population as possible with a
deviation of less than 1% and I think M
zinc may want to correct me when she
comes up whether I got deviation in
efficiency right but State districts
must be as equal as possible but are
allowed a deviation of less than 10%
through custom and case law Federal Law
requires that you follow the 14th and
15th amendments which prohibit racial
discrimination and they require the that
you comply with the Voting Rights Act
state law requires that the districts be
continuous and if a town or district has
enough people to meet the standard
deviation it is to form its own District
these criteria are some of the
traditional district and as we just
heard there are 62 um uh communities
that would have 62
errors under state law we've created 62
districts that violate the few criteria
that we do have other traditional
criteria that New Hampshire does not
have um that are included in this bill
are compactness and preservation of
communities of Interest HB 363 also
includes the emerging criteria that the
result shall not have the intent or
effect of favoring or disfavoring any
political party incumbent or candidate
for office I've included an article from
the National Conference of state
legislatures that was updated and 2021
in my submission to the committee um
that shows what other states have
adopted as criteria there's about 12
that are like New Hampshire and the rest
have more stringent Criterion about 23
states have adopted the criteria that
are proposed in HB 363
including um Alabama Alaska Arizona
Arkansas Georgia Idaho Missouri Nebraska
Nevada Oklahoma and South
Dakota um I would like to reference and
incorporate the comments of Mr Parry in
my comments uh so that I don't go on and
on and repeat everything that he said um
our existing system of redistricting
does not result in districts that fairly
represent the voters both parties draw
lines to favor their party and have done
so for decades both parties are guilty
of protecting and expanding their power
through
redistricting and our constituents know
it and are not in favor of our past
practices 74 towns in New Hampshire
passed resolutions asking for fair maps
in 2021 but they were
ignored all the people who came to
testify at the 10 hearings that we had
for the redistricting committee were
also ignored the process in 2021 was not
transparent and the majority of the
redistricting committee did not address
the many pleas that we heard in those 10
public hearings for fair and transparent
Maps the Criterion in this bill are a
starting point for transparency it will
require that these factors be considered
when drawing the new maps in
2031 jeram Mandarin discourages
participation in our constitutional
democracy and makes our constitution our
makes our constituents jaded and cynical
and worse they do not trust us and they
think think we're all self-serving and
corrupt for these reasons it is
imperative that we change our system to
make it more transparent and less
political we each represent constituents
of both parties and have taken an oath
to represent all of them to the best of
our ability not just those of our party
we must put our constituents above our
party we may never be able to remove
politics totally from redistricting but
we certainly owe it to our constituents
and our constitutional democracy to try
for these reasons I ask that you vote
OTP on this Bill thank you and yes I
will take questions perfect question got
my Flack jacket
on I don't know I feel like I got my I
feel I got my points out on the last one
um questions from the
committee representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank thank you
for taking my question um how do you
reconcile the fact that uh for house
districts we have to stay within county
lines and there are at least a couple
instances in the state where a
particular
town can does not have enough for one
representative but can only be in with a
large another larger town and one
specific Town it can't be changed
because of the County Line well actually
for house districts it is not required
to keep them within county lines it is a
practice a it is a custom but it is not
required in the statutes or the
Constitutional um but there is a way I'm
not the uh Jam manderin nerd that uh Mr
Peters is and I'm sure he can answer
that question better than I can but I I
suspect that there's a way to do it
better than what we have now and when
you follow these criteria there's
Criterion there's a better way to do it
you are always going to have ferals
unless we reduce the number of
representatives in the
state
house if only someone had a proposed
going to 391 last
time a move that a move that Mr Andrew
and I in in a weird politics making
weird bical both support it I guess um
any other questions
for representative Lane seeing none next
up is Mr Andrews who maybe we can talk
about spoke it is Mr Andrews so thank
you maybe Mr Andrew can explain why 391
was in fact the optimal number um for
for better drawings well we could go the
way I think it's either South Dakota or
North Dakota that has um just one
representative per District so that's
how they determine the number of people
in their legislature I thought it was
kind of an interesting approach I think
that's how we ended up with 400 though
is because we kept doing that and then
somebody finally went
hey okay thank
you and then on Deck will be Olivia
zinc Mr rers I I want to hear about 391
was there we go yeah 391 was a very
interesting concept I don't think I can
get into all the math in this or
but um uh I'm here to uh testify in
support of HB
363 um I think that it is a good
addition to uh CRC CRC c cacr 2 um uh
and uh it helps clarify some of the
things uh I like um the representative's
question about our communities of
Interest political parties um it says
here communities of Interest shall not
include common relationships with
political parties or political
candidates so if we uh pass both of
these then it would you know help
strengthen the uh c cacr 2
um one thing I do kind of have a an
issue with is uh section four which says
districts shall be drawn in compact
shapes and shall avoid Jagged edges and
extensions um the
compactness in terms of redistricting is
used mostly as a simplistic way to kind
of show uh Jerry mandering in that it's
very easy for me to go to someone and
show say Senate District 9 which goes
from Hinsdale to Bedford and be like
this is this is a little weird isn't it
that it's just a straight line what does
Hinsdale have to do with Bedford um but
if you take into account you know
communities of interest you can
get some districts that are not you know
kind of very compact in shapes for
instance um you know I said before we
were using uh saus as a community of
interest um sau1 is kind of very Compact
and then you have Dublin that kind of
shoots off into in it's um so like you
can't use compactness as a kind of
standard um there's a better ways to
kind of Judge whether a map is kind of
gerrymandered rather than um using uh
compact shapes and uh compactness as a
metric
um the I think I think that's I all I
had on this
um but the main the main points are you
know the section six and seven where uh
the
plans shall not have the intent or
effect of favoring or disfavoring a
political party incumbent or candidate
for office which kind of is the same
thing as cacr too but helps clarify that
language a little bit
more okay further questions from the
committee I assume you're taking
questions you were so kind last time all
right no 291 reference it's all right
all right next up is Olivia zinc and on
Deck is uh Kaye estadio for one and two
um and then after that we'll be the last
card of margerie Porter honorable marger
Porter my apologies I
keep good morning for the record Olivia
zinc a voter in Franklin executive
director of open democracy um and open
democracy supports this bill um there
there are ways that we can improve the
redistricting cycle that happens every
decade um it is important um this is an
important opportunity that we greatly
appreciate and the spe um and really
appreciate that there was documents on
the special committee for redistricting
website and the you know allowing people
to upload testimony way improved the
transparency from this decade for the
last decade um but one thing that there
was not um any kind of transparency on
was the criteria of how the maps are
drawn um to establish criteria in
drawing Maps um you would one consult
the New Hampshire Constitution and the
US Constitution on what's required
constitutionally
um but there are some great resources
from the National Conference on state
legislatures um and the Brennan Center
but there were also some resources from
the New Hampshire Supreme Court and the
US Supreme Court that were can put up as
uh guide guide posts this year um but we
were kind of astonished that New
Hampshire kind of uses this halfhazard
approach to redistricting um without
publishing the criteria that is used to
draw the maps
um regarding communities of Interest one
small thing that we would recommend is
on line 16 of this bill adding education
so racial ethnic um economic but
educational districts I think that there
are many school districts I'll just take
um with the winnisquam school district
um Tilton and Northfield Sheriff fire
district CH Tilton and Northfield share
a uh um School District but Tilton
Northfield do not share a state repb
district actually Northfield is with
Franklin and uh Tilton is with I think
was with samton but I think it got M
moved this last time so I think um
representative Harvey uh Bola would know
because that's her
District um of how those districts
change but that those communities have a
lot of shared shared water system shared
Fire Systems shared um school districts
and and that they have lots in and
representation
um you know so I think that that we
should think about putting the word
educational opportunities into that um
and with that I'll I'll close my
testimony and I have one small statement
from Jeff Smith um from eping um who
supports this and um basically says
urges the committee to support this for
the reason um that the December 2022 spe
report on the special committee on voter
confidence says partisan process in
drying electric districts has determined
undermined confidence and so he cites
that as one reason to support this and
the second reason um is the principle of
equality under law that means that every
voter eligible voter should count
equally so those are the two reasons
that Jeff Smith of eping supports that
have I take any questions okay other
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you um next up is Kaye estadio for
the
two before I confus myself again and
then we did have a late entry from um Mr
Perry thank you chairman Barry um for
the record my name is Kaye of stadio I'm
a public policy fellow with open
democracy and a Durham voter first I
have testimony on behalf of Linda Bundy
of antrum she is in support of HB
363 she says at Town meetings during
2021 voters in 74 New Hampshire town
approved and petitioned warrant articles
calling for fair transparent and
nonpartisan redistricting processes in
December 2022 one of the findings of the
report of the Secretary of State's
special committee on voter confidence
was that quote the present partisan
process for the legislature to draw
election districts every 10 years has
undermined voter confidence end quote
the New Hampshire executive Council and
state senate districts are examples of
Jerry Mander districts this bill is one
step towards establishing a process to
create Fair districts that more
accurately and more fairly represent the
voters compact districts that take into
account the communities of Interest
shared by towns maintain local ties
specifically stating that there shall be
no intent or effect of favoring or
disfavoring any political party
candidate or incumbent will prevent
Jerry mandering HB 363 establishes
standards for redistrict redistricting
that are transparent and reflect the
will of the voters I ask that you vote a
to pass on HB
363 and then next I have testimony on
behalf of Phil Hatcher of Dober New
Hampshire he says and you will see this
soon I have the receipt of my
grandfather John J Sansum which was
given in 1908 when he paid his pole tax
in mclenon County Texas today all
Americans are ashamed that the P tax was
employed to disenfranchise citizens of
our country 100 years from now what will
future citizens think of Jerry mandering
will they be a shame that it took us so
many years to eliminate the ability of
legislature legislators to choose their
voters I think so we all know that jurry
mandering which is performed by both
parties is weakening our democracy by
contributing to the extreme polarization
that has gripped our nation indeed Chief
Justice John Roberts of the US Supreme
Court writing for the majority in the
landmark case of rucho V common cause
from 2019 states that Jerry mandering is
quote incompatible with Democratic
principles but in New Hampshire we have
been unable to find a solution for
eliminating or diminishing jar mandering
in 2019 and 2020 Governor sonunu vet
vetoed bipartisan bills that would have
created a redistricting Commission in
2023 the New Hampshire Supreme Court in
a 3 to2 Split Decision found that Jerry
mandering is a non-justiciable under the
New Hampshire
Constitution HP 363 by defining specific
redistricting criteria offers a new
approach that I support because it
resonates with my experience as part of
the map non citizen redistricting
project in
2021 in that nonpartisan project we work
to define the criteria for our maps and
then we assiduously stuck to those
criteria as we develop the district Maps
this is a fully transparent process that
makes it easy to understand the choices
that were made when identifying the
Final maps therefore I urge you to vote
out to pass on HB
363 thank you will you be taking
questions are you reading and going
again no I'm all set I respect it next
up is The Honorable Mar Porter and last
Perry thank you Mr chair and committee
members and it's the honorable Bob Perry
as
well okay um I'm I'm here um ma Porter
I'm from Hillsboro and here representing
New Hampshire together which is a
nonprofit nonpartisan group that
encourages citizens to meet together and
find Common Ground solutions to problems
um and as I mentioned earlier in my
testimony they are in support of this
bill because one of their um solutions
that got and I have to correct myself it
got 89% approval from the members of the
uh assembly was to establish an
independent redistricting commission um
I have with me copies of the four
recommendations that came out of that uh
citizens assembly for anybody who might
be interested I didn't bring a lot of
them but you might want to look at them
so I'm I'm urging the committee to um
please vote to Art to pass this bill
363 thank you okay will you be taking
questions sure are there questions from
the committee seeing none last up will
be the honorable Bob Perry and next time
Mr Perry I don't refer to you as St of
introducing yourself please feel free to
committee I I speak in support of HB 363
I will be very brief I did not intend to
speak given personal time constraints
but it was not enough for me to just
sign the sheet in support my
presentation on cacr 2 has a similar
theme to it that is providing more
detail for map designers and the courts
but as a statute can be implemented much
more quickly though subject to
reversal indeed this bill at Roman 6 and
Roman 7 contain similar language to that
of CA ACR which addresses and is
consistent with the concerns I raised in
the
cacr the last sentence in Roman 5 also
relates to my presentation on the cacr
and although not given its own Roman
numeral here speaks to the detail needed
for courts to understand the intent of
the statute the intentional use of the
word
practicable at Roman 5 simply means map
designers use their best efforts to
comply given the complications of
Designing Maps especially for house
districts I hope the so-called New
Hampshire Advantage will include passage
of laws in the Gerry maning Arena that
consider people before party passage of
this bill would be an excellent
beginning I urge
OTP thank
you and will you be taking questions
from the committee Mr Perry yes are
there questions from the committee see
none thank you um I don't have anyone
else signed up speak on the blue sheet
there was two in favor one opposed
online there was 341 in support seven
opposed Zer neutral that I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
363 and the committee will stand in
after
was
not
okay it's it's 10: it's 10: a.m. I'm
going to recognize representative toner
for the purpose of introduction of uh
House Bill 356 enabling school districts
to adopt partisan School District
elections good morning I'm Travis toner
um I represent bellnap 4 which is the
town of Belmont um I'd like to introduce
House Bill 356 uh the bill enables the
school districts to uh choose whether
they can adopt partisan School District
elections and I will not be taking
questions awesome I only have one pink
card uh it's uh Eric power Mr power
law is it a printed testimony or is it a
reference a reference
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
uh election law committee for the record
my name is Eric power I live in
Brookline I'm a 30-year resident um I
currently serve on the planning board in
in Brookline I previously served on the
Hollis Brookline Cooperative School
Board uh I am the President of the
school district governance Association
of New Hampshire and um I'm also the
secretary of the Brookline Mason
Greenville Republican committee or the
clerk uh role I've held since 2009 so
I'd like to speak to you uh in favor of
House Bill 356 I'm here representing
myself by the way um enabling school
districts to adopt partisan School
District elections and really the
purpose is is enabling legislation it
lets school districts vote to see if
they want partisan elections and so
what's the motivation for this well
first is increased voter engagement and
turnout um nonpartisan Municipal and
School District elections around the
state have top have turnouts that top at
25% maybe um 10 to 15% or less is common
um the ones that have the higher
turnouts tend to have SP2 voting because
there's things to vote on um but if you
look at partisan Statewide elections
like in presidential elections in our in
our uh midterm elections the voter
turnouts two to three or four times
higher um and you know we've had we had
some recent ones that were 80 90% in the
last in the 2024 election um part of the
reason to that one of the big reasons is
that partisan ballots have more
information for voters they create more
interest in turnout and most voters have
a general idea if they don't who the
candidate is they have general idea what
a republican means what a Democrat means
and they find this information useful in
making their decision
this bill also is sort of enabling at
three levels the first level is it
enables the school district to decide if
they want to have the uh elections the
second level is it enables the town uh
committees the Republican Town committee
and the Democrat Town committee to hold
caucuses to nominate candidates for the
school district offices this caucus is
not mandatory it's optional so it's
enabling each year
um each Town party can decide if they
want to have a caucus to nominate the
caucus would be held in the January time
frame I think it's six Fridays before
the uh actual election is the deadline
and um if candidates don't want to
participate in the caucus or there isn't
one they can actually self-nominate by
getting 50 signatures from members of
their party in order to get themselves
nominated as a Republican or Democrat on
the
ballot the thing that's another in is
that each individual candidate can
decide if they want to be part of the
partisan process so if this passed in a
school district people could ignore it
and just file as they do today they can
stay as unaffiliated and they would be
so on the ballot so really it's got a
lot of choices for it and I think it's a
good thing um if you have a partisan
School District ballot it'll look a lot
like our state ballots you have in
November you'll have a republican column
Democrat column and unaffiliated column
that rotates by random ordering by the
Secretary of State using the same
process today um like to mention you
know I've served on the school board um
on a co-op School Board across two towns
and while officially they're
nonpartisan underneath they really are
partisan in a lot of ways because a lot
of the local education policy choices
and budgeting choices are driven by
partisan beliefs that's where people
come from they have those biases and
they have those beliefs so um a school
board under elected also elected under
partisan system can hold Pro caucuses
just like you do in this committee and
you do in the house and in the senate
members of the party can have a break
hold a private caucus to discuss issues
I think that's valuable because as you
know it helps organize and negotiate
with the other side if you privately get
together and you help find common ground
so it's a useful
tool um how familiar people are with the
uh process of partisan elections they're
already available for municipal uh
purposes so you can do Municipal
partisan elections so this law and this
bill actually references a lot of that
and adds to it uh as necessary for the
specifics of a school district and I can
answer questions more on partis
elections if needed um we did find that
there was a a small amendment that
should be added to HB 356 I think it's
already been filed by representative
weary and it would be adding uh new
section 7 to the bill which would
basically update RSA 95 or 91a the about
the right to know but just to add in
that if there a if there's a caucus it
could also include a school district
caucus if it's elected on a partisan
basis and also reference the new
RSA so for those reasons I would
recommend otpa on House Bill 356 to
provide school districts local Town
committees as well as individuals the
option for partisan elections to help
increase voter engagement and turnout
thank you very much okay will you be
taking questions yes I will are there
questions representative
Lane thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and normally I
wouldn't put somebody from the public
necessarily to ask a lot of questions
but um none of the sponsors are here
so we've been hearing or we've heard
several bills one bill that talked about
a single a nonpartisan ballot a single
ballot in order to decrease polarization
and
partisanship and was something that a
lot of people wanted this spil kind and
you had statistics so this bill kind of
goes the opposite way it it says that
increasing
partisanship increases
participation and I'm just curious about
your statistics versus the ones that
we're hearing about the bill and where
you got those and and frankly if you
could repeat
them well I mean I've looked across the
state you know both in my community and
in other uh communities and you see
turnouts that are in the you know 10 15%
range I think there was a bill in uh
Municipal and County government that
talked about not even passing a warrn
article unless there was a certain
percentage and it was like 15% so that
was you know set that way because of
that reason um because people don't know
who the candidates are and you know
that's a problem um with if you don't
have this partisan uh ability and so I
think having this as enabling
legislation it lets each each Community
can decide for themselves if it's a
useful tool for them to adopt so if they
if the if the majority of Voters in the
school district want to have it they can
vote for it and if they find later that
they're not it's not working for them
they can resend it um I do think that
people don't like the term partisan it
seems to be a a negative term to some
people but partisan does give you uh an
idea of the person's background and the
person's you know General beliefs on how
they're going to vote so it's more
information for the voter so you you may
not know the person's name but if you
see they're a Democrat or you see
they're a republican it provides more
information and some people and I've
talked to people in my town that says
why do I vote I don't even know who the
people are if I knew there was
Republicans and Democrats I would
actually be more interested in voting so
um it's it's a little bit of uh I don't
know if there's actual statistics on it
but it's um something I've I've run into
and I've talked to people across the
state and it seems to be something
that's um of interest and it's just an
option and if you know if an individual
candidate might be be a Republican and
say I just still want to stay as an
unaffiliated and they're not required to
declare that they just file as they do
today with the school district
clerk um so they're not like I said it's
enabling at many levels it's enabling
for the the school district it's
enabling for the town uh political
parties and it's enabling for each
individual so I think it just allows
people to decide for themselves if it
works for them thank
you represent Gilmore thank you Mr chair
okay my problem I'm looking for your
thoughts on this my problem is in the
city of Dober which I represent the um
city um election is
nonpartisan yet now we're introducing a
partisan at which point in time the
school board is also elected and I'm
just seeing the problem here with having
a partisan School Board election while
you have a nonpartisan city election and
I just curious of your thoughts thank
you for the question representative
Gilmore so um we have Town elections a
lot of people have the March 11th I
don't know where the cities have them
they might have them at different times
but on that day you're technically
having multiple elections there are
separate ballots so if you're in Dober
say that your do voters wanted to have
partisan School District elections that
would be a partisan ballot for that one
but maybe your your Municipal ballot
would remain nonpartisan so it's a
choice on each one you could have both
of them nonpartisan as I think it is
today or you could have one or either
it's not required that they all have to
do it at the same time they can each
decide to do it as it makes sense for
the community yeah just clar Dober in
any municipality can adopt a partisan
ballot system for their local election
including the city of Dober if they
chose
to yes they
can but now we're basically separating
say can you adop one but not the other
oh okay I see the point you're raising
and um the issue also is the municipal
election in do is in November at which
point the school board is elected just
for
clarity each I just want to clarify so
each the decide decision to make
Municipal partisan elections is one
decision with a separate warrant article
in question and the decision to do a
school district partisan election is a
separate warn article and a question
they're not necessarily related their
independent decisions it can be proposed
by voters or governing bodies further
questions from the committee
representative wood I didn't see you com
in I apologize yeah thank you Mr
chairman and I apologize to you and the
board for being late this morning I was
question what I wanted to know is you
mentioned earlier that you had data on
um looking at the voting records of
different towns partisan versus
nonpartisan and I was wondering if you
could submit that to the board if you
have any data in writing I do not have
data in writing um on partisan versus
nonpartisan I just have some cursor uh
looks at it but you can every time you
look at a a turnout in any election
that's a like a November election for
the state when you're getting elected as
representatives and the president
Congress those numbers are always
substantially higher than you'll see in
any other municipal election I think our
town clerk Brad
when we get above 20% um and that's a
fraction of what um you see um for
everybody's reference um in my research
I found that there is um one city that
has
Municipal um partisan elections in the
municipality is Portsmouth so they if
you look at it they'll have RS and D's
on their ballots so um it's out there um
and but uh I think it you can't do it
currently for school districts and
that's the purpose of this bill
is the chairman further qu yes for would
followup please
yep um from from the data that you look
through what do you think would be the
top reason for that big discrepancy 20
80% people not voting uh what do what
what do you think is the top thing I
think thank you representative wood for
the question I think that the major
question is and I've heard from people
is if you don't have S SP2 for your
school district your town what do you
you don't have much to vote vote on you
do not have um a lot of contested races
you don't even know who the candidates
are it tends to be a lower profile so
there's less information but even just
having the RS and the D's for some of
the candidates I think that provides
information and motivation for voters
because they'll feel like wow I can make
a difference I have more information and
it's
available that's why people want to vote
when they feel like there's something
they can vote on and they understand it
and they have the information so I think
that's the reason for this thank you any
further questions represent Nome thank
you thank you for the qu for taking the
question um am I right when you said
that there's only one town or city that
has adopted partisan elections that's
what's I don't know representative I
don't know if it's been done in the past
that's the current status that I found
yes okay thank you further questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
uh I did have a late entry
representative
vone welcome to election La I don't
before thank you Mr chairman I really
appreciate the uh the
greeting um as a former Civics teacher
this is a really really interesting uh
bill I speak in opposition to it I speak
also as a budget Committee Member a
zoning Board member uh Rec ation
um town and
schools issues are generally considered
nonpartisan and I think we should keep
it that
way if you think about the level of
partisanship and the intensity of the
vitriol that is going on right now do we
really want to introduce more
partisanship in our
state going to ask that question really
second
thing who's the biggest block of Voters
in the state it's not Republicans not
Democrats it's
Independence and I'm going to tell you
that in the um the campaign that I had
last fall I spoke to well I I spoke to
probably close to 2,000
people
and the biggest comment was they like to
vote for the person not the
party they like to vote for the person
party so keep that in
mind also and I'm going I'm going to
speak against the the uh there's a
similar bill on on town is that whether
the town needs a new plow truck isn't
issue and also as a conservative
conservative Believe It or Not There are
some of us conservative Democrats
when it comes to spending some of the
biggest spend thrifts I've ever seen on
the budget committees are Republicans so
this notion that somehow you're going to
get a lot of information from the from
the r or the D beside the person's name
I think is can be called in
question and then
finally we have a hard time just finding
candidates to run
period how many more people are going to
say do I really want to stand up there
and put myself into this
whole the this whole Whirlwind of
partisan politics where I'm going to be
attacked for being a Republican or I'm
going to be attacked for being a
Democrat think about
that is this what you want to
do I hope not because this is this is
just going to further I think further
The Divide in this country and we need
healing in this country and we need
healing and actually when I see how Town
politics have worked in eping yeah the
turnout is lower but it's a lot higher
under spe too that it ever was as under
under town meeting or School District
meeting and we just everybody showed up
one day you never had you never had a
big turnout
anyways so I think the argument about
generating more turnout is specious that
means I don't think it really holds
water and when I see some of the other
bills on elections coming out here I
just see more of a a partisan lean on
trying
to just introduce more partisanship
um so I'll be back to talk against the
town one I hopefully have more to say on
that one but thank you very much all
right will you be taking questions sure
representative Gilmore oh back to Dober
um so the go the municipal election in
Dover is governed by the city Charter
would this legislation take precedence
over the city Charter that was adopted
obviously by the people of do that's the
question I don't know I'm not a lawyer
me neither so I'm not going to say one
way or the other I would think so but I
mean that's just my guess uh further
questions um I I have a I have a
question so you said that unaffiliated
voters represent the
largest group but isn't it also true
that Republicans and Democrats together
there's more of them than there are on
Affiliated voters so that the majority
of Voters in New Hampshire are actually
partisan
voters it depends on which election
you're you're looking
the partisanship level goes up on
presidential years and it goes down
afterwards if you look at the records if
you look at the numbers over the last 30
years you'll you'll see that and I'm
just going to come back to you and just
say yeah do you want to see the kind of
argument argumentation That's goes
on that happens right now between
Republicans and Democrats on the
national level and at the state level
and you want to bring that down to the
to the local level then vote for it
that's what you're asking for I'm saying
is we need I I like Town politics in
part because it doesn't matter what you
are and if you go and you looked at the
eping budget committee you'd be hard
what and that's a great thing in this
day and age in
2025 and so if you want to take that
away then Vote for This
thank you for taking my question
representative um uh is the supervisor
public I think so yeah followup yes so
if it's available for the public
wouldn't anybody be able to see how a
candidate voted in the previous election
yeah and also I mean it does come out I
mean we have candidate forums and people
show up in there and they can be asked a
question about but guess what nobody's
ever asked that question and I go back I
mean I've been doing Town politics since
I was 11 I've lived in the same town all
my life and I've been to a lot of
candidate forums and nobody's ever asked
are you a Republican or a
Democrat it's more about should we have
the plow truck or not should we vote for
the teachers contract or
not oh get ribson
qu thank you Mr chairman o sorry
thank you um thank you for taking my
question are you aware of any data that
uh would give us some insight into how
the political sympathies of Undeclared
voters kind of uh play out in terms of
party sympathy like polling or whatever
so uh thank you for the question
um you know it's it's knocking on doors
talking to people so I mean how how it
turns out for the voters that I I talk
to
um I mean one of the things I mean I do
know people who do not like to be pigeon
hold and they want to be able to vote
for a republican when they think there's
a good Republican in the primary to vote
for and they want to be able to vote for
a Democrat when there's a good Democrat
in the primary um so I mean that's but
that's definitely just observational and
imper okay go representative wood come
back represent wood thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh this bill does not mandator
change the voting it's up to the
district it just allows them to enable
them why would we not want to give the
towns the ability to make their own
this thank you that's a really good
question so we want to have some towns
to have partisan elections I I just
think it's a really bad idea that we
should just keep that off the table and
if you do enabling legislation you put
it on the table so in towns where some
people really want to make part of
Mischief then they may put that in and
then all of a sudden I think you're
going to see a different disc so I would
just say leave it off the
table further questions representative
Lane thank you and thank you for taking
my question
um if we go this route and a town enacts
a
partisan uh election would that prevent
an independent or an in unaffiliated
person from running
do you
think well it says a message that I
think it's it's I think it's I mean
right now everybody runs as an
independent right a local election so
everyone's equal right and are are you
aware that oh may you have F that's okay
um are you aware that I when often when
we recruit candidates um they are
registered Independence so we have to go
out they have to go out and change so
that they can run because otherwise they
would not be able to run I mean I don't
know if you're aware of that fact or not
I think it's I know that's true for
state and uh State and national
elections yeah that that is true okay
thank you all right further questions
for representative alone who will
probably never come back to election off
for
this that was a joke it was not in it's
and I would be back to this afternoon I
know it was if you watch the Comm it was
a tongue and- cheek comment it wasn't a
derer statement um all right I think I
don't have any more pink cards um
online uh online but believe it or not
for being a very partisan committee we
usually get along pretty well um
356 I already have open seven in support
332 in opposition zero neutral represent
gusovsky what do we got on the blue
sheet uh three three in support all
against three against on the blue sheet
with that we'll close the public hearing
on House Bill 356 and open the public
hearing for House Bill 590 recognize
represent the toner for the purpose of
introduction um just so you know
representative Wei are the sponsor on
this bills and I messed up and scheduled
it for the week he was gone so that's
why he's not here was I messed up um it
it's not uh I believe he sent Mr power
in his in his dead but it was it was a
scheduling error not a um not a lack of
apologies good morning election
committee uh if you ask me questions
when I'm done would you please speak up
I just got over a
respiratory illness I'm fine but it
affected my hearing for some reason I
don't know why but it did okay I am
representative Louise Andress I
represent Mary mat County District 5
andova Danbury Hill Salsbury and
Webster I'm also Al a citizen in the
town of Salsbury which is a part of the
Mary ma Valley School District which
includes the towns of bosne Lowden Penny
cook Webster and
Salsbury I have been involved real good
totals when it comes to voting so I went
into so I went
into the SAU office last year after the
election and I've done it
before and just for curiosity I
counted Salsbury in Salsbury 61 people
voted for the Schoolboard
candidates and yet there were
45 votes for the candidates in
Salsbury one thing it happens here with
a small town like us we only about a th
voters May more or less I think I know
there's more but when you get into the
bigger towns they have
253,000 voters and there's no
way with all the towns
voting for the
candidates that a small town even a
bigger Town last year the town of Lowden
had a very viable young candidate they
worked very hard but there's no way
because the whole District voted for for
the candidates in in in the town Alden
there's no way they could get him into
office I don't know if it's viable to be
able to make it so that or if it's even
legal that you can each vote in your own
town for your school board members and
the other towns can't but I really wish
the com committee would consider it
seriously
as many people in our towns would like
to vote for their candidate and they
don't want anybody else voting for them
and that's all I have to say about it
thank
you okay representative Andrew will you
be taking questions from the
committee oh yeah I'll take questions
but you're GNA have to speak up so I can
really hear you all right are questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
only have one other card um Mr power
back up and uh representative toner can
you grab the blue sheet for me since
well maybe we can get him I don't know
do thank you again election law
committee and Mr chair again I'm Eric
power from
Brookline um representing myself I'm the
president of the school district
governance Association of New Hampshire
and also uh I served on the Hollis
Brookline Cooperative school board for a
three-year term so I'm familiar with
Cooperative school boards Cooperative
school boards should be cooperative
among the
towns um I was in a two-town um
Cooperative School District with
Brookline being smaller than Hollis and
um we do it I think the right way where
there's three school board members from
Brookline and there's four Schoolboard
members from Hollis so a seven total but
only the Brookline voters vote for the
Brookline representatives and only the
hollus voters vote for the hollus
representatives and I think that makes a
lot of sense but there are school
districts and I think I've heard of a
couple like Hillsboro Dearing and um
also I think in exer Regional where all
the voters in the entire Co-op vote for
each Town's um representative so if
you're from
Brentwood the brenwood people vote for
you but so do all the people in exiter
and everything so same thing at
Hillsboro Dearing you know the Deering
reps are voted by everyone and that's
kind of a problem I think if you're a
small town and I think representative
Andrew was speaking to this why wouldn't
just the voters from your town be able
to vote for your representative
otherwise um you're going to get the the
the pr preference of the larger town
dominating and deluding the vote and you
wouldn't really have a representative
you have one from your town but you
don't really have the M you don't it's
not really selected by the people in
your town so I think you have a couple
bills in election law this is one of
them um I think this makes a lot of
sense so this would say basically um if
you're from Dearing only the Deering
voters would vote for you not everybody
in the whole Co-op and I think that
makes a lot of sense in order to really
make the co-op cooperative and and it's
a matter of fairness um that that that
happens so I think that you know I would
recommend this bill I I support this
bill and it would correct some of the
unfairness that you've seen across the
state I think this bill has come up in
the past but this is uh I think this is
a good solution thank you very much okay
will you be taking questions from the
committee yes I will uh representative
wood yes you mentioned uh two different
situations one Cooperative where they
were voting individually and and one
that um represent Andrew mentioned um
wasn't the same do you know the is there
a legal reason for this a structural
reason do you know what the why there's
different
situations thank you for the question
representative wood yes there is um it's
it's a decision in uh RSA
195 um where there's a there's about
five or six different options in
selecting it and you know when they form
a co-op you're deciding which one you
want but that can be amended and um but
I think the ones that have this I don't
think it's really a fair method and the
problem is unless the legislature acts
the Big Town has the power and do they
want to give it up and allow it to be
changed in their articles of agreement
which is sort of the Constitution of the
co-op they're not going to ever do that
they're never going to want to give up
their power they get to vote if they're
a big town they get to vote for the
people from the little towns and you
know they get to pick who's on the
school board but I think it's a it's
unfair to little towns for that to work
that way so I think that's why this
legislation is important so that little
towns actually have a voice in a co-op
it's it's almost impossible to get out
of a co-op um withdrawals are very
difficult that's a whole another issue
but um even making a change like to an
articles of agreement is a majority vote
across the co-op and it's never going to
go through with the Big Town maintaining
their power and you know that's the way
that's just the way people are thank you
thank you further questions from the
committee representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um in some districts
including March Valley school district
there are both uh Town selected
Representatives or at least the person
has to reside in the town but there are
also some at large districts that go
over uh more than one town do you see
that as a a uh an issue that would still
large interesting question I think you
could still keep an at large and then
the only the voters in that at large
District would vote for that person it
would be sort of like state
representative some state
representatives only represent one town
but some state representatives represent
three towns but you don't have people
outside of those three towns voting for
that so I think that that that's
workable um with the at large districts
like the March uh
Valley thank further questions repr Lan
um is this a way to have I guess what I
voting um representative L I'm not sure
if I understand the question about
proportional voting but it would
basically you know a lot of the co-ops
will have so many um they're required
and this also gets approved by the State
Board of Education when they set up a
Cooperative or Regional School District
they have to have the one man one vote
rule so they do have to apportion the
representatives based on the uh the
popul the voting populations in each of
the towns so that's where that happens
when you have that um that's how it's
done the second level is who are the
ones that vote for those so you know
maybe in the exiter they might have
Brentwood might have one rep yes they
have one rep and that will person will
have to be from Brentwood but who votes
for that person is the question is it
only the people in brenwood that's the
secondary question that's what's being
solved by this bill or is it everybody
in the whole exitor Regional Co-op that
votes for the BR the the Brentwood rep
so that's that's how that would work
thank you that's very helpful okay thank
you so further questions um so I this is
not an area that we deal with much in
election law so we're I had to read 195
which is is not an RSA 600 so my brain
immedately stopped so what I'm looking
at is there's basically five different
methods the school district can choose
to elect to to to figure out their
composition for their school board right
and what this bill is trying to Target
and I don't know if this is properly
worded um but with just so understand
that the problem this is trying to
resolve
so at
large at large to be voted on by
everybody if you're if you're an large
District like I think everybody here
understands that concept but there's a
it looks
like4 as a option for composition allows
for a board where it mandates that a
person has to come from a
town but members from another town can
vote for that person from that town and
this bill is trying to say no no no if
you're going to go that method that only
the members of that town can vote for
that member um
like that's the intent that's what it's
trying to get to right it's not it's not
trying to say because I think there's a
way this could be read that say it's
like if you're running at large that
only the people in your town could vote
for you um which I I I I don't think
that's the intention of it but I think
it could be read like that right like
that's the point you're trying to get at
yes I I agree with you okay all right
all right thank you that that I just
wanted to make sure I think if we
forward this this probably needs to be
reworked on language you I think but um
any other questions
hearing none thank you um and late entry
Horan so I'm I'm resident Timothy Horan
from Strafford County District 10 which
is a uh one-town district with four
members representing the town of Durham
um it's part of the oyster Cooperative
school district and actually my first
term I represent a state leg legislative
district which for some bizarre reason
was uh exactly Co exactly coterminous
with the school district which is
something that hasn't happened in the
last two desial cycles I've been here uh
I've been here since two s my when I
started running that was like my
district was based on the 2000 census um
and um so we have the system where there
some seats that are uh designated for
the for the uh smaller towns in the
district and I'm I live in the largest
town so I may be prejudiced but I I
don't necessarily think that it's unfair
that the voters in the larger town have
more influence because uh this is a
democracy and there's a lot more of us
in my town than the others and in any
case I'm not sure if there's that much
conflict between Durham Lee and Madbury
um over what school I mean there's a lot
of controversy over how the school dist
run but I don't think like the people in
Madbury have that much a different
opinion about how the school district
should be run than those in in Lee um
Madbury has about I think probably about
5% of the population Durham has you know
poke about six two-thirds of it and then
Lee has what's left over so I don't
think there's actually a lot of
difference in how the people in the
three towns feel about educational
policy so I I'm not sure um so I'm not
sure why uh Madbury just because it's
I'm not sure whether they're mberry even
though there's few of them feel any
differently than the people in Lee or
Durham so I and um so I think it's you
get huge um and know as you know Mr
chair being on having been on the rition
there's huge uh one person one vote the
statistical part of that is extremely
extremely important and like very
difficult to deal with and this creates
humongous uh one person one vote issues
because the way I read in my school
district they kept it same the voters in
Madbury would be and there's nothing I
love m adbury I Wish I Still represented
I love campaign there but I'm not sure
like
whether they deserve you know whe 5% of
the population should have like you know
whatever it is 15 you know they would
have like it would call create huge
disproportionality for the smaller towns
in the district and um and um so I I
also so I think this is a this is a bad
I think this is a bad Bill going to
create it'll probably be challenging
courts cre to create massive one person
one vote problems and I'm not sure if
it's really necessary most
cases um and also course the other of
course it's uh also probably will point
out is you you hinted at uh this is kind
of an unusual assignment for committee
this issue would usually turn up in uh
either Municipal and County government
or education policy and administration
why they dumped it on you when you got
plenty of votes so I don't know so so I
think um yeah so Al I'll also say I
think the way this bills written the
wording of it is kind of questionable so
I'm not sure how that affects the at
large districts um you know the at large
members so I
I'm um so I I CH one one extending St in
my school district is that uh the
largest Elementary School that serves uh
Durham is actually located uh just over
the Border within the borders of the
town of Madbury and also a large number
of the elementary school students go to
the mway school in in in Lee so you know
the uh end Durham does currently does
not actually have an elementary school
so that maybe makes finds the three
towns more closely together than they
might be otherwise so I I would just
urge you uh either have to totally
rewrite this bill or uh just probably
the better alternative just itl it or
you can probably also refer it over
Municipal and county or educational
policy Administration and let them deal
with it
so I I certainly
I certainly you know I've been voting
for The Madbury and Lee Representatives
as a resident of Durham and I think I've
made uh reasonably good reasonably I
think I've made good choices I think the
people we've chosen aren't any better
aren't any worse than they would be if
only Lee was voting for that Lee
representative mberry right so thanks
will you be taking questions from the
committee are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you don't
have any more pink cards there was no
one on the blue sheet and and
online it was eight support 115 opposed
one neutral with that mcgl we'll close
the public hearing
on um HB
590 and I will open the public hearing
for HB 367 changing the method of
adopting partisan Town elections to be
the same as resending partisan Town
elections um and representative weie
couldn't be here and I scheduled his
bill because I'm a jerk um so represent
toner can you do the old uh intro no
me and I did Apologize representative
wor when I realized what I did when I
was looking through who was going to
God good morning represented Travis
toner I represent bellnap 4 um town I'm
town of Belmont i' would like to
introduce House Bill 367 and I will not
be taking any questions
perfect uh next pink card up is Eric
Brookline thank you uh committee members
Mr chair of election law uh my name is
Eric power from Brookline here
representing myself I do serve uh as the
secretary and Clerk of the Hollis of the
of the Brookline Mason Greenville
Republican committee and I'm here
speaking in favor of House Bill
367 um it's a very simple bill um what
it what it does is it change it makes
the method for adopting partisan Town
elections the same as the way to resend
them so under current law the uh the way
to adopt a the partisan Town elections
is via uh a warn article
and if you're at the traditional meeting
it's going to be a a traditional meeting
uh uh warant article if you have S SP2
then it goes to the deliberative session
and then goes on to the official ballot
on Election
Day um if you have already have partisan
elections today you um you you have it's
it's required to be to resend it uh to
go back to nonpartisan it has to be an
official ballot question whether you're
in sb2 or you're in a traditional
meeting so um what this bill is doing is
it's just making it the same going both
directions so it says that if you want
to adopt partisan elections that it
becomes an official ballot question it
goes on the ballot on Election Day
whether you have a traditional meeting
or sb2 for the voters to
decide um and the same as you do today
for the um
resending the other thing that's
important is that there are a number of
official ballot questions you may be
Familiar of of things that are required
to be official ballot questions that
have to do with elections if you want to
elect your planning board and I
mentioned I serve on the planning board
we we've we've transitioned recently
from appointed to elected that's an
official ballot question it goes on the
ballot for all voters to decide and our
and our voters decided overwhelmingly to
go that way and then the following year
we there's an official ballot question
question for the Zoning Board of
adjustment overwhelmingly the voters
voted for that that was on the official
ballot um there's also one for the
Conservation Commission if you want to
change your Conservation Commission from
appointed to elected that's an official
ballot question because it deals with
the election so it makes a lot of sense
when you're dealing with an election
issue for it to be also an uh an
official ballot question and um so that
way it would enable the voters that
there's many more voters that vote on
Town election and School district
election day than do on uh the go to the
annual meetings or the deliberative
session so this just makes it uh a much
better option for uh choosing this and
making it the same to choose to have
partisan elections or to
testimony are there question are you
taking questions Mr power yes I will are
there questions from the committee
representative Lane um again I thank you
for taking my question um I think as our
chair recommended we don't see these
kind of bills very often so it's a
little bit of an education for us so I
guess I'm reading the existing statute
and it says that the town can adopt the
partisan official ballot system under an
article in the warrant for any town
meeting and may resend such action in
like manner
so the purpose of this bill I
thought was for the method for adopting
it to be the same as resending it don't
we already have that if I'm reading the
existing statute
correctly so representative Lane I do
not believe the current statute is
consistent I know you find might find
that shocking but
uh this is a bill and I did a little
research on this that was written in 197
79 it was House Bill
766 um by representative Ramsey of
Stratford 13 I did
766 House Bill 766 in
1979 that's that's the year of the bills
in April of 1979 I that's older than the
online archive so I had to go to the UNH
online to find it uh the scanned version
and they did a good job actually um and
so this bill has not this part of the
bill hasn't been changed since
1979 and um as a piece piece of
Education they used to talk there was a
number of bills when I was looking in
1979 they were talking about large towns
being 4500 so there was a lot of 4500s
of population were a lot of bills in
election law and in other places that
were was used and over the years that
has disappeared except for in two places
one of them is in this bill um is in uh
RSA 66 6913 and the other one is in RSA
23162 B which has to do with electing
whether you want to elect a highway
agent for two or three years believe it
or not and they made a differentiation
uh there between a a town that's 4500 or
larger or not so there down to two
places where the 4500 has not been
amended uh out and OB obviously New
Hampshire has grown a lot since
1979 so what's consistent here it would
basically there was this is the existing
law so it's saying um that if you uh
have a large town then you have to to
resend it by the ballot which doesn't
make sense because most towns that are
4500 wouldn't be considered large today
in in um New Hampshire so this actually
does make it the an official ballot
question going both directions
regardless of the size of town it makes
a lot of sense and uh brings us you know
brings us consistency I think previously
or the current law it would depend you
know you would you would weend it by a
warrant article I guess if you have less
than 4,500 residents but if it was
greater than 4500 you have the official
ballot for some reason so I don't know
why that's the case um somebody in 1979
thought that was a good idea but I think
it just makes sense to have an official
ballot question to adopt and an official
ballot question to resend because it is
an it does affect the election so it
makes a lot of sense for voters to weigh
on that like you choose to elect your
planning board Zoning Board of
adjustment and Conservation Commission
thank
you question representative
Burnham thank you Mr Powers for taking
my question thank you Mr chairman um I
just uh have a question if when these uh
petition warn articles uh including
these
RSA uh laws uh are received at the
deliberative session does it give
opportunity for people in the audience
to provide an amendment changing actual
statute thank you for the question
representative Burnham I believe that's
a gray area but I think it's more clear
that any um warrant article that's
required to be an official ballot
question should not be amended um at the
deliberative session think about this
for a second um if you have an off
ballot question and you have a
deliberative session now you're saying
they can modify it but what if you have
a traditional meeting it just goes right
onto the ballot and there's no
opportunity so I think the intent and
this is probably a municipal and County
government question more than election
law but um I think that it makes sense
that if something's prescribed as an
official ballot question it should maybe
be debated at a deliberative session but
not amended I think that's the proper
way to go and I would say that would be
the same for this law here that we're
talking about thank you further
questions from the committee saying none
thank you um next up is representative
vone and I don't have any other pink
cards for 367 so representative gasowski
me thank you Mr chairman mark vone from
Rockingham 5 eeping this is going to be
really brief because this
bill I'm not losing sleep over this bill
as as I was over the school Bill however
I and I I unfortunately not able to be
here all day but I would be uh
commenting on the number of partisan
bills that look to highlight partisan
elections and to restrict the vote of
Independence I'm going to uh your
hb220 so my concern here today is that
we don't need more partisanship in 2020
now whether this bill actually needs to
be uh enacted because we're going to try
to uh update an old statute that is your
decision that is your
purview but if it's in the spirit of
trying to instigate more partisanship
and elections and I would say vote no on
this
please okay will you be taking apologize
will you be taking questions represented
BL um sure all right that was long pause
I expect it other questions
seeing none thank you I don't have any
other pink cards for
online help if I had 367
open online was six in support 209
opposed on the blue sheet was two
opposed with that I will close the
public hearing for House Bill 367 what
were the numbers on online again uh six
support 209 oppose thank you um and the
committee will stand in recess for 6
for
e
okay it's a 11: a.m. uh we're going to
open the public hearing for House Bill
481 relative to moving the state primary
date and going to recognize
representative Schultz for the purpose
of introduction representative Schultz
welcome to election law thank you Mr
chair it's really great to be here to
talk with you all about this bill I love
that these conversations that I've had
with your chair in the recent past have
been very positive I thought his speech
on the house floor really echoed a lot
of the thoughts and feelings I had about
the state primary and needing to move it
and the and the point that this does
this sound really super echoey I don't
know if I should move further away all
right um but the one uh quote that
really
um I just still have stuck in my head in
a good way is uh your chairman said the
existing primary is an incumbent
protection plan
essentially um and I couldn't agree more
so let me take a step back hi I'm Chris
Schultz I'm a State Rep from conquered I
represent Wards four nine and 10 Ward
four is where we're sitting right now so
welcome to my district um I first
arrived to New Hampshire because I
managed a Governor's race for Mark
fernel the second one not against jeene
Shaheen but the one that Craig Benson
ended up winning so if you loved Craig
Benson you're
welcome but we did have a tough primary
um I though
H come with the experience of having cut
my teeth in nine other states um and
worked on campaigns and elections and
then capitol hill to to a degree still
doing that work um for 16 years uh most
of it not in New Hampshire I worked in
my native state of Kentucky they have a
May primary I will say because I grew up
in that I have a partiality to that date
it's sort of you know the last thing we
do before summer kicks off but when I
was growing up there I also worked in
primaries in Nevada Iowa Wisconsin New
Jersey
Virginia South Carolina Washington DC
Pennsylvania and I'm forgetting another
state and New Hampshire so uh that was a
wonderful experience to work uh for
presidential campaigns I managed a
congressional race and a Governor's race
I was executive director of the New
Hampshire Democratic party um I worked
for Al Gore Bill Clinton uh a labor
union program for Barack Obama I worked
for John KY so anyway there's a very
very quick version of my resume I only
say that to say I come with the
experience of having seen firsthand the
impact of when the primary date is and
how that impacts the general election
and I think the part that's nonpartisan
here and I would love it I was almost
wish we could have a dialogue with the
chair because I know he agrees with some
of these points and some not probably
but um I feel strongly having first from
my experience with that governor's race
and then how it has continued on in the
Democratic side and it does seem to have
been longer on the Republican side that
having a 58 day roughly on average
general election really isn't enough to
recover from a major uh difficult
primary you know I'll just put it out
there maybe I should save it for a a
democratic caucus to talk about this but
we need trans transparency in this issue
um on the Democratic side it was a rough
transition for Mark fold to go from uh
that primary to facing someone who was
spending millions of dollars on Boston
TV you know and talked about an income
tax that was impossible but you know
regardless of what his message was to to
rebuild that connection and recover from
and earn the trust from uh Bev huling
wor supporters we didn't have the time
to do that and communic Comm unicate
with your general election voters we
also can look to other Democratic
primaries on the Democratic side the
Andrew valinsky uh Dan felus primary was
brutal and I love both those guys but
they never you know it never recovered
the campaign staff certainly never
recovered there still are some some bad
blood among folks who worked on those
campaigns you know I will say our last
gubernatorial primary was brutal and I
can see what has happened on the
Republican side it hasn't exactly been
uh you know puppies and rainbows there
either and I just say on that campaign
you know it's sort of Just Party
politics on this level you know it's
hard to Pivot when campaigns are all
about pivoting pivoting from your
primary message and who you're speaking
to and who your message is directed at
and you know these things are very much
drilled down on who's going to be the
deciding factor to a much different
audience general which is now I'll say
here's the part that affects the average
Granite stator and why we should move it
to only hear from your general election
candidates and their general election
message for 58 days it really does give
an added bonus as the chair said on the
house floor last year to the incumbent
in a way that doesn't favor
democracy uh you know I love our our
federal delegation but they're not
always going to be our federal
delegation as a Democrat I would love to
have a Democratic governor at some point
while I'm a State Rep but for grat they
need more than 58 days to have that
conversation you know it's a whole other
slew of people who don't care about I
mean we're notorious for this even
though Independents can pick either
ballot and a primary there's still a
bunch that don't want to do that they
don't want to align themselves so much
that they don't want to participate in a
primary as a voter
and they're eager to see what fleshes
out for the general election ballot and
I just feel very strongly um that it
would be better for everybody to move
that primary to I loved this this was
essentially the Senate bill from a year
ago um that the senate had passed after
editing and it went back and forth this
was the final version sent to the house
um in late May of last year and I
thought that that June date was a great
date um I think there are other ways we
could because I think that's you know if
you're just voting on one bill with a
date that's difficult you know if like
well I'd prefer August or well I'd
prefer July I don't know um I'd prefer
before Labor day but just before Labor
Day you know there's many there are a
lot of strong feelings for all of us of
when it should be I'd suggested that we
informally with the House and Senate
knowing that Democrats are in the
minority is fine we did a sort of rank
Choice voting of the top
10 possible that you guys could come up
with possible choices and do a rank
Choice voting of that and see which one
is the first or second or whatever I
realize the governor is going to play
heavily in this conversation I don't
know to what degree Democrats will be a
part of that conversation but I think
coming to the point of not just looking
at one day or the other we need a
process that we can work together on
that isn't just All or Nothing on one
date and that's my suggestion to this
committee I'd be happy to um do all the
leg I'm not some big rank Choice voting
Advocate per se but I certainly can get
access to the the software I believe we
could get it for free we could do it in
an informal way it doesn't have to be a
part of a bill it could be you know like
a work session for the whole legislature
include the Senate that's just my
suggestion but if we don't do something
like that and this bill is being
considered I do think that this is the
best time for us to have it it gives us
a couple more months to Pivot and to um
rebuild those
relationships really for the the part of
the ticket that it impacts the most I
don't I don't I feel like we as state
reps will adapt to whatever it's going
to be we are a scrappy uh devoted group
of people who really know our voters I
feel like we will pivot even if it's you
know we move the deadline for filing
earlier I feel like the part of the
ballot that is going to impact this in
the good way the most are the races for
governor US Senate Congress probably
executive counselor to some degree and
in some State Senate races um I also
will send to you I did research the
filing deadline of all the states in
America and when they filing deadline is
and ours is among the latest but some I
think let me
uh seven states have their filing
deadline in the year before the election
year so if you're running in
2026 in those seven states you file in
the end of this year so and then it
varies four file in January four
February 12 in March 9 in April 3 in May
s in June and only three states have a
filing de deadline that is later than
ours that may have changed since the
last um legislative cycle I will double
check that before I forward this to you
but um and I know that those States also
were looking at moving their primaries I
think Rhode Island is one that is
already doing that so literally almost
the entire rest of the country has an
earlier F filing deadline and an earlier
primary than we do there used to be
quite a few mainly in New England that
had a September primary and I think in
the near future will be one of if not
the last in um Delaware and Louisiana
and rhod Island those are the three
states who had later than us and it
looks like they've been working to move
it as
well so anyway I mean there's a lot of
other things I could say about this I
will forward that about the filing
deadline I think that was the one of the
biggest difficulties that the Democratic
house Democratic caucus had at the time
a year ago was concerns over when the
filing deadline will be and you know I
still I'll reiterate I feel that we as
state reps can adapt to whenever it will
be and yeah change can be painful but I
think knowing that it's really important
to the top of the ticket and all of
those above us I feel strongly that we
need to make this change and you know
within a year or less even we'll find
that that adapting to that schedule for
State reps is fine it just means we keep
talking to our voters our constituency
you know are you not going to talk to
your constituency during a session you
should be I should be we all should be
you know I hope you don't wait till June
to start talking to your constituents
but um I don't mean that in a judgy way
I'm just saying we can we will adapt as
state reps we're Scrappy we can do it
but we need to not think about ourselves
in that way we need to think about the
top of the ticket um I just realized are
you a co-sponsor of this bill that's why
you're sitting up darn I wish we could
have a real
conversation um anyway again I realize
Republicans are going to weigh much
heavier than we Democrats are but I'm
going to do my part to work with the
Democratic house caucus to see if we can
GA gather better support for this and
moving this um I know that there are
folks who've worked on campaigns in you
know the recent years Al those staff
would definitely as far as I could tell
would like to have an earlier primary
for the most part and um I would be
happy to do more work in Outreach with
the Democrats but having said all that
um I'll answer any questions you may
have well thank you for your testimony
do we have any questions from the
committee representative wood thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for uh sharing your experiences and your
thoughts on this um I believe you uh you
answered this but I want to make sure I
was clear because you did a pretty good
job talking about the difficulty and
picking the day the month whatever I
believe you said that you were in favor
of the
June okay so that's true can I follow
up yes so I just want why are you in
favor of the June well I think the
earliest we could have it the better
based on all those states that I've
worked in um you know
traditionally I think of Summer
beginning here around Memorial day but
for practical purposes kids are usually
in school till mid June to do it before
family vacations start kicking off would
be good and I think um that would give
us a good compromise between what I feel
would even be better dates which would
be earlier than the date in the bill and
those that would prefer a July or August
I feel like that is literally the
midpoint of when what could be
best
um yeah I think that that just juggles
the whole idea have family vacations and
when folks start summering both as a
noun and a verb in New Hampshire it
gives folks the time to have some
vacation as voters you know and then um
we already know who our candidates are
for the general election and that
messaging can start I feel like that is
a good compromised date but you
know I'm tempted to say what date do you
think would be good
but thank you thank you
do we have any further questions from
witness seeing n thank you very much
thank you Mr chair and I really
appreciate your time on this and hope we
can keep talking about it till we can
find the most
amenable date and eager to see what our
governor feels about this as well thank
you you're welcome uh next uh I'll
recognize chairman Barry who will be
filling out a pink card yes we'll f p
card I won't um belabor many of the
points I just want to point this is a
bipartisan bill so I want to thank
representative Schultz for approaching
me to sponsor it um June would put us
basically in the middle of all these
states so right now we're last or dead
last depending on how you want to look
at it uh Louisiana just changed the way
it does its primary system but they've
historically used what was called a
jungle primary so their election day was
technically their primary but if you had
50 plus one then they didn't have a
general election um so I don't know how
you want to bracket that in um but June
to put us like right in the middle um
August appears again to be not an option
so um you know the house has the house
has voted for June the house has voted
for August the house has voted for
August again um but it it's June or bust
again and I don't say it's my way or the
highway because once again I will point
out I have voted for June I have voted
for August I don't care I just want to
move it um I just don't want it to be in
September so you know the the the 45 day
window
that basically our current primary
crates is a massive incumbent protection
plan um it's it's I I kind of warned
actually this body when I was trying to
do june a year or two ago I said one of
these days you're going to have a
situation where in an Open Primary
you're going to have one party starts
running their their one of their can
starts running away and then you guys
are going to get caught in a contested
primary and you're going to lose
something like the corner office and
then boom that's exactly what happened
um the Democrats got caught up in a um
Cindy Craig uh Joyce Craig bit her
primary uh govern now Governor aot kind
of ran away with her primary she was
able to Pivot off um and go straight to
the general election while the Democrats
were marred up uh chasing each other to
the left and you saw how that worked out
so you know it's not this it's not to
say that Democrats are evil in this
situation the same thing could have
happened to Republicans it could have
literally been the exact other way
around um it was just going to happen
and it happened to the other side first
so I would really hope that we could
consider June again um because it's like
one of those deals of like the beatings
will continue until morale improves um
morale needs to improve on this the the
notion
that that we're still in session in
April is like
ridiculous how many of you were
primaried in the last one and and very
little of them were even successful you
know we're always kind of oh we can't we
can't do the primary because we're we're
in session we can walk and Sh gum at the
same time um I think this Committee of
all has how quickly you can move if you
want to um and to representative Schultz
Point how how dare you assume that
you're not talking to your constituents
for two years you know it it shouldn't
be an issue for an incumbent so I I've
been very consistent on that I I hate
incumbent protection plans even when it
might favor my own party I I find them
to be anti-democrat uh small D
Democratic um and I think general
election voters who are the bulk of the
voters they deserve to hear from our
candidates both sides uh the idea should
play out on their merits not who
happened to push through their primary
the quickest um and that's exactly what
has happened so um I'm happy to take
questions but I do have to piece out at
11:30 for a meeting so I'm glad I got in
there soone F my pink card up but I'm
happy to take questions and I don't want
to be um repetitive to representative
Schultz's excellent excellent
remarks yes representative Lane to tell
me why I'm oh sorry I'm not chair right
now good Lord I'm not chair right now I
apologize I'm so used to being chair yes
you've made me acting chair yes I am
sorry that was so rude that so and the
uh witness has told us of his
willingness to take questions do we have
any questions from the
committee representative Lane thank you
um now I forgot the question
no my recollection is there was concern
about the amount of money that might go
into the campaigns if we start earlier
there's just going to be more money
coming in is that of any concern
to you at all I I know it was raised
last year I just yeah I I don't think
that's a concern because the money is
going to get there regardless um and
it's I I I think that kind of the to
Pivot off of your question there I think
the bigger question is is when does the
Challenger get access to their funds
right so you know right now we have the
three periods the pre-filing we would
call it regular people call exploratory
but pre-filing um and then there is um
the primary and then there's the general
funds right so if you're a if you're a
challenger right you're probably going
to raise most of your funds for the
general because your primary if you're
in a contested primary a lot of the the
donors are going to back off to see what
happens right um so you may not get
access to your cash that until the very
end well when you get it with 45 days
left it's far less effective there's
already a lot more you know stuff flying
it's harder to break through through at
that point um earlier cash in terms of
campaigning effectively is better
because there's like when you're
campaigning you're in this um you're in
this quandry which is the closer you get
to the election the more people are
paying attention right but the closer
you get to election the more everyone
else is spending so there's more noise
and there's this Sweet Spot somewhere um
where there's not a lot of noise and not
a lot of uh but enough people are paying
attention and I definitely don't think
we're in that sweet spot now I think
we're way too by the time the Challenger
gets access to what could offensively be
a third of their funds probably actually
bring on it's probably closer to half um
you know they have 45 days to unload it
and I think in the last in the hearing
from two years ago somebody raised up
like well they can campaign in the
general and the primary at the same time
I like well no they can't um you know if
they have limited funds or they're in a
contested primary they have to campaign
to the electorate that's going to elect
them first which is the primary AR
electorate um and you like the easiest
example of that is direct mail right so
if you're in a contested primary you're
only going to send direct mail to the
houses that vote in the primary you're
only that's the only thing you're going
to do because if you don't do that right
if you say all right I'm going to do the
primary and the general electorate and
then that other person beats you in the
primary well guess what like so what you
campaign to the general elector it
doesn't matter you're not the nominee so
it it's the the system is kind of set up
with these hurdles in front of it and
all I want to do is move that last I
guess the second to last hurdle the last
hurdle being the the general election
but move that second to last hurdle back
a little bit to give both sides an
opportunity um to compete and I I think
it'll be better for voters to hear from
you know the the vast majority of Voters
do not vote in a
primary they don't it's like going to be
20 25% turnout so like three4 of the
voters are not voting in that and to say
34s of the voters are only going to get
talked to um directly you know they
might be able to get you know if they're
watching the right TV station or
whatever they might be able to get a
message um but if to say to kind of just
exclude them and say they're only going
to get 45 days of talking to um is is
kind of ridiculous and also when you
bring in the absentee ballots right so
absentee ballots are usually around 10
to 15% of the election and when you
think about when absentee ballots go out
like specifically uok Cava right uok
Cava ballots go out 45 days on the nose
before the election 45 days so if that
case that voter is getting that ballot
in their hand um they're probably
getting that b voting the hand they've
maybe had a week and a half maybe maybe
two weeks of general election activity
um to offensively make their choice so
if we're going to be for voters making
informed choices we have to allow the
candidates to make their pitch and let
the voters decide on their merits
because if you want to reduce partisan
activity the worst thing you can do is
not let them inform not let a inform
them inform the voters about themselves
because now the voters are going to do
what they're going to vote on the only
piece of information that they have in
front of them which happens to be party
and they're just going to you know go
down one column or the other so if you
want to actually kind of state if you
want to do what you state you wanted to
do which is reduce partisanship increase
you know cross ticket balloting you need
to let both candidates from both parties
have a more equal you'll never get fully
equal but a more equal opportunity to
make that pitch um and you know let the
ideas let their ideas and their Pitch
live or die on their merits instead of
living or dying on did they have a
contested
primary okay thank you do we have
further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much
representative
yes oh is one up there for me
already uh seeing no further pink cards
to testify for HB
481 representative gazowsky would you
get me the blue sheet
please
[Music]
and
okay okay
interesting all right I see uh PR Pro on
this bill and I see no
opposed I do not have a
representative Barry's access to the
online uh stats I'll ask him
respectfully if he could announce that
far
us all right and I will call the public
hearing for HP 481 to a close at this
time
who
pink
oh oh okay got it that was for
representative
fine okay 481 was 10 and support eight
oppose three neutral and um uh
representative qua has the con because I
have a meeting at 11:30 but I will be
okay with that uh we'll open the hearing
408 is uh representative Oregan is here
the bill and I have um some written
testimony but I'm not sure whether they
supposed to pass it around the table if
you would place it on the table in front
of you please okay everybody will get a
okay representative Morgan yes and and
there is a cop version of my written
testimony on the online portal but it's
actually a slightly I amended it after I
put it on the uh on the portal but um so
I'm resident Timothy hor straford County
District 10 the town of Durham and um
even though I have my doubts about the
June primary I'm grateful that
representative Schultz is the co-p of
this one because we were both interested
in an earlier primary so this
issue of moving the state primary has
come for this for the house election law
committee many times in the past I
myself have sponsored two such bills
neither of which went went very far one
of them was like virtually identical to
this one but I think I had a different
Tuesday in August in mind um so what
this does at least is introduced it
would move the state primary to the
fourth Tuesday in August of the even
numbered years that means the primary
would henceforth be held sometime
between August 22nd and August 28th if
we passed this uh if we pass this at
least if at least if we pass this in
2025 this next day primary would take
place on August 25th 2026 and the status
quo you all know is a second Tuesday in
September of even numbered year which is
between September 8th and September 14th
and actually September 8th is uh when
the next uh State primary scheduled the
held that's actually the day after Labor
Day which you know that having any
election on the day after holiday poses
some a few logistical difference
difficulties they're actually fairly
minor we've had like many for example
presidential primaries held on the day
after well at least we have had at least
some presidential primaries for example
held on the day after President's Day
and we we've managed um anyway as as
we've been talking about just a few
minutes ago when that happens at
Secretary State and the other election
officials have 49 days get ready for the
general election rather than usual 56
day which poses major logistical
difficulties just given all not just
mailing out the UA ballots but there's
all kinds of other things that happens
recounts I actually like went through a
recount in
2022 um there's ballot ballot law
commission challenges we had one in
straford County shortly after the uh
actually after the filing deadline for
the county commissioner's office in June
and there's all just a variety of other
things that can happen so and uh as you
also alluded to back in the previous
bium the House pass HP 115 so that
started out it was introduced as a June
primary bill it was amended by
bipartisan and veto proof majority in
the house to be an August primary bills
I think it was the last Tuesday in
August and that got turned back into its
original form was a June primary by uh
is it okay to say the senate in a
committee meeting anyway the other
legislative chamber on the other side of
the
wall and uh then it went to the
committee conference process and the
house rejected it um there was a lot of
concern that if we pass an August
primary bill which I I definitely
absolutely think we could have gotten it
through the house um the other body um
they vot did everything by V votes we
don't know what the exact numbers are
but it's probably conceivable that 16 of
the 24 members of that unnamed body
might have been interested in this bill
in a in an August
primary we're very worried about the
governor at various you know all kinds
of things um actually the committee
report in the house went on and on about
like how there's no air conditioning and
school houses Etc and I'm not sure why
that's an argument for June over August
it's both actually August late August is
probably like not as hot as mid June
when we'd be having a June primary but
any case we have a different Governor
now so we we um she has different ideas
about things I'm not sure if she's
really
Express an opinion on this but anyway
the governor who was here two years ago
is not there anymore and you know as I
said I'm repeating myself but yes that
August primary it got through the house
with a veto proof veto proof margin so
it's a pretty good chance we could have
gone to an August Primary in two years
ago
so what's what's the good side about it
well if we has HB 408 the election
officials would have several more weeks
prepare for the general election I think
we would have if I remember if I did my
math correctly it'll be either 70 days
which is 10 weeks or 77 days which is 11
weeks anyway they have a much more
comfortable cushion before you know they
have to send out the yukaba ballots
before they do all the recounts and any
ballot law commission um challenges and
so forth and I think a late primary is a
good thing first of all gives voters
more time to make their
choices um and also less unknown
candidates have more time to catch up
with the Front Runners um
we're talking about the governor's race
last time and actually we had contested
primaries in both parties for governor
but in the case of on the Republican
side Governor ayat like out distance you
know she was beat all her Challengers by
a huge margin although we had two fairly
evenly matched candidates on the
Democratic side I'm not necessar if they
necessarily drove each other to the left
I'm not sure whether they're going
farther the left was necessarily a bad
inherently a bad thing but anyway we did
have two Challengers and actually the
one I think was better known Statewide
ended up prevailing anyway that was
Joyce Craig although so I think and as
legislative candidate it's much better
for legislative candidates like us and
I've actually I've been through actually
several contested primaries even though
I'm in a very blue District so whoever
comes out of the
primary you'd have to run a really
really bad campaign to lose in my in U
in my district but we we've had a number
of contestant primaries and uh
which uh so that gives um that gives the
challengers more time to catch up with
the incumbents but also it's it's um the
later primary is better for the
incumbents do just for the simple reason
that uh sure we can walk and chew gum at
the same time but it's probably better
to do one or the other if we have the
choice um so that you know that you know
that gives it if we if we head the
primary in June the filing deadline
moves forward to to March and that you
know a lot of times people haven't even
decided what they want to do over the
next two years by March you know like
lots of people make the decision based
on what happens in the last you know few
last couple months of the second year
session and um also then you'll be busy
both for the uh incumbents and the
challengers you're you know raising
money which I have no objection to I'm a
capitalist I mean money may play I think
money has a role in politics maybe too
big a role but I'm not uh I'm not averse
to collecting donations and spending
money and sending out mailers and doing
other things um so it You' be doing that
at the same time you're also trying to
do your legislative job you be putting
out your signs in the spring doing all
kinds of things just I think the current
life cycle of the at least the
legislative elections it's it's a lot
better to be doing that in the summer
after most of your legislative work is
is done so especially especially in this
cycle when the legislative office will
be will be closed and we'll be up the
streets so we won't um
we'll probably be having like very very
we'll be having even fewer meetings
during the summer of of 2026 than usual
but that's uh neither that's a topic for
a different committee so I just think
it's better to have filing year near the
end of the second year session and I
think also having a later primary is
good for the voters also because also
like the issues that they're deciding in
August or September like to be similar
to what they're deciding on November so
we move it all the way forward to June
there'll be some case is where we'll
nominate somebody in June and then it'll
turn out to be a bad idea because of
what happens between you know June and
November and you'll also have the
problem as we've seen in other states
where people get nominated and then
decide they don't want to run after all
and then you have to Scurry around and
go through the whole process for
replacing the nominees so I've um
probably given way too many reasons but
anyway I just think it's I think we need
a slightly longer window but I don't
know whether totally I think it's not
necessarily the totally restruct
structure the whole way our election
cycle works so therefore that's why I
think a late August primary um which
several other states have like including
our neighbor across the Connecticut
River or should we be calling it The New
Hampshire River now but anyway the our
neighbor on the other side the connectic
riv Vermont does it and it works well
and so I would uh I would urge you to uh
I would urge you to pass this bill like
we had the chance two years ago we have
another chance now so I think we should
take advantage of it so i' be happy to
take any questions okay thank you are
there any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony uh next up I have a uh request
from Secretary of State David scandin to
testify and thank you for joining us
once
again well thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm David scandin
Secretary of State and as consistent
with past years I would Express a
preference for uh an August
primary that's not to say that the
reasons for a June primary are not valid
and I think uh representative Schultz
and Barry did a good job explaining uh
you know their concerns that is more of
a political component than than a
logistical one which is what I'm going
to focus on uh my remarks um there's no
question that we need to move the
primary further back from the general
election
um we are on a really tight time
frame uh in meeting the federal
requirement of getting absentee ballots
out to Military and overseas citizens
they're known as uocava voters and uh
when we have to conduct
recounts in that in a very narrow window
um it can be challenging and I can tell
you that I was holding my breath in the
last primary because there were a number
of hotly contested races uh for Congress
and Governor that you know at least
right before the election looked like
they could be close enough to Warrant a
recount and uh had that happened we
would have gotten the job done but it
would have been a Monumental task so my
concern overall is spreading out the
workload of Elections over the course of
a year a June primary
uh would mean a March filing period and
it would mean ballot preparation shortly
after that that's at a time of year of
course when many towns most towns in the
state are holding their Town elections
and their Town meetings and so there's
already a significant workload for uh
local election officials and also my
office and being a resource to the are
uh pretty well attended by voters
and I think in August state would would
continue that uh that process it would
keep a filing period sometime in the
June May June time frame that it
currently is I think that would have
less impact on local election officials
dealing with Town elections and U uh
that's the reason why I would favor this
bill a little more than the other one so
I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you Mr secretary do we have any
uh representative wood thank you Mr
chairman for take ask for allowing me
ask a question thank you Secretary of
State
um it just seems like a lot of effort to
move it just a few weeks uh to give you
a few more weeks uh time that can you
you know why the last Tuesday of August
I mean holidays I I just don't
see how how you're going to get the
relief that you're looking for so can
you explain that to me I think two weeks
makes a very big difference and in the
time frame of what we have to work with
after an election uh we could conduct a
major recount in a two-e period so I
think it it takes that that concern off
the table and we would be able to meet
our requirements to our military
personnel that want to vote by absentee
ballot the the other consideration that
I have is is earlier in the year where
we have events prep preparing for the
state primary that are in very close
proximity to town meetings and you know
that causes uh time issues with local
election officials and obviously we're
very concerned about that want to make
sure that you know the whole process
runs as smoothly as
possible thank
you representative C you requested uh
opportunity thank you um you mentioned
you support August rather than June is
there any particular week in August that
you I like having it as close to the
traditional September primary as we
could but but um we can do the
job with the fourth Tuesday that that
gives us an additional two weeks um you
also are there any other questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you very
secretary uh seeing no further uh
requests uh from Witnesses potential
Witnesses representative gazowsky thank
well I was uh I was prepared to read the
online testimony it was a u
unfortunately uh the Chairman's laptop
timed out on
me so was something on the order of uh I
can gra I can grab that Mr chairman and
in about two minutes at the most so I
can pull that out
okay
but I I'm going to I'm going to proceed
with the um public hearing oh the uh
public hearing for hp48 is
closed uh I'm going to proceed with the
hearing for uh
HB
151 so and we have representative Lex
perne here to introduce the bill which
he
sponsored oh it has it has an amendment
but anyway please proceed Vice chairman
uh quae uh members of the committee my
name is Lex Bary and I represent Grafton
District 11 which includes the town of
Grafton Alexandria hebr and gron uh the
bill in front of you HB 151 simply
reduces the term of the supervisor of
the checklist from 6 years to 3 years
Cindy Klick a select woman in Grafton
requested that I file this this bill in
the hopes that reducing the term length
will encourage people to run for the
supervisor of the checklist the feedback
we've received from potential applicants
is that six years is too long of a
commitment that's basically the bill and
the rationale um I've passed around um
an amendment uh proposed by uh
representative kab uh this amendment
acknowledges that the supervisor of the
checklist is on the town election and
not the general election it also cleans
up the language a bit but the intent of
the bill remains unchanged um I hope
that you will consider uh this amendment
and uh pass the bill as amended uh I can
take any questions but if you have
questions about the rationale and those
kinds I think the people speaking behind
me would would be able to better answer
that thank you okay thank you do we have
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you I am
I'm going to defer at this moment to
secretary scanland
so he can return to his other duties
more quickly thank you Mr secetary thank
you Mr chairman I appreciate you letting
me do my job um you're
welcome uh so I'm David scanland
Secretary of State uh and I support this
bill uh just briefly you know when uh
individuals are looking for at running
for this office uh they see a six-year
term in front of it and that is pretty
intimidating uh I think this is a time
when when we're trying to encourage
people to participate uh in local
elections and run for office uh there's
been a decline in that department uh
over time and I think having a
three-year term is certainly more
appealing to people if they know it's uh
not a lifelong commitment so um with
that I'd be happy to answer any
questions okay thank you do we have any
questions from the committee
representative Ward thank you Mr chair
thank you secretary scandin could you
just confirm for someone who's desperate
to know that this only applies to towns
cities this would be for elections for
Town supervisors of the checklist cities
are a little bit different and that they
appoint registrars to maintain the
checklist so yes follow up in our city
they get elected okay for two-year terms
so it's this does not apply to cities I
no no this would be for towns all right
thank
you are there further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
you uh next up is Cindy
today
the my name is Cindy click and just a
slight correction of a former selectman
in the town of graft and I am no longer
one but um I'll be brief everybody wants
to get to lunch and I'm just going to
repeat what the first two gentlemen
already had to say um I asked him uh
representative brne to submit the bill
for the legislature's consideration this
session because we had two of our three
supervisors at the checklist resign last
year in our town and we were hard
pressed to find people who were
interested in making such a long
commitment even now we have an open seat
that no one signed up to run for as I'm
sure most of you know uh finding
volunteers is a real challenge these
days so our hope is that changing the
term from six years to three years will
give folks considering Civic involvement
one less hurdle to
overcome uh also put the positions in
line with other um offices in town um
the only other one that has a different
uh term of office than three years is
the moderator which is only two years
just like you guys and the governor and
the executive counsel and everyone else
so
I'm asking for you to please vote a to
pass on this and help us make it a
little easier for others to say yes to
helping fill these important positions
thank you for your time and thank you to
the co-sponsors who signed on with
representative
bney thank you will you take questions
from the committee absolutely thank you
any qu any questions from the
committee uh representative
Gilmore thank you
um
the as the supervisor the checklist
myself for three or four terms I could
not believe I would ever sign up for a
six-year term um but that's not my
question my question really is um what
about I in the Ci's um my city it's a
two-year term is two or three
preferable to
you I I think considering how much there
is to do with the job I I think three
years makes more sense and in two years
I think it I I I've never done it I've
never done the job I don't know um we
like like the previous question that uh
Secretary of State scanland answered
this is just for towns so it wouldn't
affect
cities okay further questions from the
committee representative Newsome did I
see your hand up no
okay so see seeing no other questions
estadio
observing thank you representative qu I
just have very brief remarks um one from
Jeffrey Smith of eeping he is in
opposition to hb1 151 he says this is
because it overlooks the extensive
knowledge and experience the position
position requires in order to support
free and fair election
processes and then I also have testimony
from Karen Dodge of der um she says as a
New Hampshire constituent and voter I
ask that you please oppose HB 151
changing the supervisor of checkless
term of office from six years to three
would be unwise a six-year term allows
each supervisor to hold office through
all the various types of Elections
presidential state and local and she
reasons that this is important so that
the knowledge of each type of election
is run and can be passed on to newly
elected
supervisors thank you thank you will you
be taking questions no okay well thank
you very much for being
here uh seeing no further requests to
testify representative gasi would you
get the blue sheet please and while he's
he's getting that I I actually got a a
list
here uh to go back to hp48 408 for a
moment
online testimony was 10 in support 10 in
opposition and neutral
2 and uh for
hb11 which we about to conclude there
were 11 in support opposed
212 in neutral Zer and thank you to my
colleague Who provided this information
to me and to representative Newsome for
his helpful this and uh being willing to
do that thank you both there's the blue
sheet for and here's the blue sheet I
see
three people testifying in favor of this
bill and with that I will conclude the
hearing for hb1 151 and we can all go to
lunch and we'll resume at 100 p.m. thank
here
e
so we are going to reopen the house
selection law hearing for House
Bill
151 correct no 600 we did no we did 151
I didn't should be fair it's why it's
not scratched off House Bill 600 FN um
which is established rank Choice voting
for Municipal elections and recognized
representative Reid for the purpose of
introduction thank you so much Mr chair
thank you honorable members for the
record my name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 new market and new Fields
uh for those of you who may be new or
not familiar I will briefly go through
rank Choice voting as a concept and then
get into the specifics of the bill rank
Choice voting is a system of voting that
is designed to select the winner with
the most support sounds reasonable right
um it eliminates in doing that it
eliminates some of the problems with our
current system which we call first pass
the post those problems being what we
call vote splitting or or the spoiler
effect um and also the need for
strategic voting and I'll get into that
um the first ranked voting system was uh
proposed by a philosopher by the name of
Raman lul um who is out of where we
currently call Spain um in the late
1200s uh the first country that adopted
it was Denmark In
1855 it was adopted for national
elections by Australia and Ireland over
a hundred years ago in all of this
obviously is before voting
machines um and today it's used by many
countries uh including uh Malta and
South Africa where it was proposed and
successfully reduced uh civil tensions
was the reason for one of the reasons
for its uh adoption it's used in dozens
of municipalities in the US going back
for over a century here in in the US
it's used by the States of Maine and
Alaska and it's used by Southern States
which have runoff elections for their
absentee overseas
ballots um and I'll get into why that is
in a minute it's also used by hundreds
of large universities corporations and
organizations and has been for quite a
while so the problem is that when you
have three or more candidates running
for one seat you may very well end up
with a winner which we call a low
plurality winner this is a winner that
has less than 50% so you may with three
people running you may end up with a
winner with only 34% which means you
have 66% of the voters that may have
wanted one or the other of the people
that didn't win and would have coalesced
around that person and definitely didn't
want that other person who won so that's
what we call the vote splitting problem
and because we have that vote splitting
problem that spoiler effect we are
forced to strategically vote and by that
I mean only two candidates ever matter
in an election the way we currently run
it with the first pass the post system
the candidate in the lead and the
candidate who's the closest to knocking
out the candidate in the lead everyone
else beyond that doesn't matter and if
you're voting for them you are throwing
away your vote which means that most
people don't feel like they get to vote
their conscience get to vote for the
candidate they truly want because
they're forced into one of those two top
two candidates um so not only is that a
problem in that we don't get to vote our
conscience but that creates this forc
strategic voting because of the spoiler
effect which is why we have our de facto
two-party system that everybody decries
is terrible that our founding fathers
told us over and over again warned us of
that um parties would be uh terrible for
our democracy so because there's no
strategic voting in ranked Choice voting
it allows more candidates to run because
everybody can run on even playing field
you don't get knocked out just because
you're not one of the two mainor parties
um which means you have elections that
represent a broader range of views um
and also it increases voter turnout
because voters start to feel like their
votes matter and that they can vote
their
conscience so the way it actually works
the nuts and bolts is it works very much
like a runoff election in states that
have runoff elections you may know
that what happens in a runoff election
is that If no candidate gets a majority
in that first election they will
eliminate for runoff election purposes
they'll eliminate everybody beneath the
the top two candidates and then they'll
redo the election and have people vote
again the benefit to this is there's no
additional election you don't have to
wait time you don't have to spend money
on an expensive election you don't have
to have an reduced voter turnout in that
second election you just put who you
would vote for in a runoff election on
that same piece of paper which is why
those southern states that have runoff
elections do it for those overseas
ballots because they don't have time to
send out another ballot so they've been
using rank Choice voting for quite some
time so on a ballot everyone ranks their
preferences it's something that everyone
instinctively knows how to do with your
ice cream your pizza toppings everybody
knows how to rank their favorite
whatever um and if there's no majority
Runner after running first preferences
then the very last not all candidates
but the person who comes in last gets
eliminated and they're voters then are
reallocated to their second preference
and you just do that by round until you
end up with somebody with a majority or
until all the rounds have been completed
and so if there's one thing to
understand from the RCB as a concept
it's that ranked Choice voting is
designed to result mathematically with
more people happy with the results of
the election as opposed to our first
pass the post uh system so as for this
bill this bill is very simple it is only
an enabling Bill and and of itself it
does nothing it enables municipalities
and only municipalities to adopt rank
Choice voting only for Municipal
elections only if the town's people
choose to adopt it for those Municipal
elections so it goes to a vote of the
people it allows for the recension of
that uh adopting rank Choice voting so
they can unadopt it by the same exact
method that they adopted it it's not
more difficult it allows adoption of
rank Choice voting for certain offices
and not others if a town wanted to do it
just for one office or a few offices and
it provides that it has to be adopted at
least 90 days before the election for
which it's going to apply so Town
elections as you uh may have recently
spoken about today actually Town
elections are
nonpartisan um so while some in the past
have tried to uh propagate narratives
that RCV is somehow a partisan issue um
it is impossible for this particular
iteration even be partisan I would um
argue though that this is desperately
needed for cities that have either
runoff elections or primary elections
like Manchester and nasua because they
are holding entirely different new
elections costly
elections whereas this would save them
all that money tens of thousands of
dollars at a minimum and I just looked
at Manchester's budget yesterday to find
out that number so having an additional
election whether it's in the form of a
municipal primary or in the form of a
runoff uh cost the people money it also
is reduced turnout people don't like to
turn up to the an election twice in
within a few months um reduced turnout
and lots of time and unnecessary work so
these cities will definitely have every
reason in the world to opt in the
machines that have been certified by the
SOS are already rank Choice voting ready
they are ready to go results are tallied
instantly it's also really quick to do
it by hand and in fact we will have a
little chocolate demonstration at the
end of your day so you can see how
quickly you can do a rank Choice voting
election by hand um and there is no if
if a town or city decide to adopt this
there is no end of organizations that
are willing to educate educate Andor
train um for any town that wants to
adopt this so New Hampshire rank Choice
voting is ready and willing Fair vote
legal Women Voters did education in
Maine I imagine they'll be willing to do
the same thing here the rank Choice
voting resource Center and there are
more organizations than that so there
will be a just embraced by many
organizations uh if you if a town
chooses to adopt this so this cost the
state absolutely nothing cost the state
nothing in money cost the state nothing
in trouble because the secretary of
state is not involved in any municipal
election um and because select boards
and town councils city councils weigh in
on ballot questions if there was some
concern uh on the municipal level about
adopting rank Choice voting that could
could be communicated on the town
warrant and voters are unlikely to go
against those recommendations unless
they have good cause so just to sum up
this does not mandate anything it simply
allows towns to do what the voters want
whether they want to opt in opt out only
for specific races um but enables the
towns to save quite a bit of money time
and trouble and increases voter
participation and helps more candidates
run and with that I am happy to take
questions are there questions from the
commit and I accidentally shut off your
microphone I pressed the wrong button so
you have to turn it back on yes sir
thank you uh representative Lane uh
thank you for taking my question um what
about the current ballot counting
machines can it handle this or would
this require a whole new round of ballot
counting
machines so the current so it depends on
what town adopts it the towns that have
received new machines those machines are
are CV ready so the new machines right
but I and you would know better than me
uh what is available to towns to help
them adopt it if a town a hand count
Town wanted to adopt this it's obviously
something that the people of the town
would consider before choosing to vote
for it but again it's been done since
the on the national level since
1855 so um doing it by hand is not an
issue it actually isn't that much more
time than doing a first pass of the post
election by
hand further questions representative C
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh I didn't see in
here any way of uh handling uh voting in
multiple locations I'm thinking of uh
for instance Manchester which has 12
Wards 12 voting
locations while each Ward only votes for
one Ward counselor they all vote for
mayor right how do you get the ballots
or the information from the ballots from
one place to another it's not mentioned
in here right because it's up to the
town how they want to centralize you do
you raise a good point that you do in
any rank Choice voting you have to
centralize ballots or the number the the
data so whether that's done as we
currently do for example by couriering
we currently Courier tape on for State
elections Courier the tapes to the
Secretary of State's office night of an
election in a similar way you would have
to Courier something or if the town
wanted to somehow digitally transmit
that that would be up to the town that
would there would be a lot of concerns
around digitally transmitting but um
they could conceivably do that in some
sort of secure way but you would have to
centralize either if you're going to
take all the ballots or take all the
memory cards or what have you youd take
it to one location and you'd run it all
through the same
reader further questions from the
committee saying none thank you oh I'm
sorry M Lane I apologize oh uh I did get
a message that probably includes myself
uh we need to speak more into the
microphones I've got oh okay somebody
watching at home is saying nobody can
hear anybody asking
questions
um how would this work and maybe this
doesn't happen in a city but if you have
multiple win like if you need more than
one winner and I don't know if that
happens in a city and whether that's
just an academic conversation or right
so multi-winner districts um is so when
rank Choice vote this is actually a
wonderful thing when rank Choice voting
is applied to multi-member districts so
that's something like for example my
State Rep district has three
Representatives representing and you're
voting for three in that election when
rank Choice voting is done in a
multi-member district it's referred to
as single transferable vote and the
wonderful thing about single
transferable vote combining multi-member
districts with uh with rank Choice
voting is the results end up
proportional I actually spoke briefly on
this when we were talking about the uh
Open primary bill but um So currently
let's say you have a district that's 60%
one party 40% the other party um if you
have three seats all three of those may
go to the the one party that has 60%
when proportionally you would want two
of those seats and one of the seats to
represent the other 40% and Naturally
Speaking that's how um this turns out
when you apply a single transferable
vote to a multi-member district so so
that's actually good now is in terms of
whether I don't know for sure if any
municipalities have a technical
multi-member District you certainly have
the opportunity like if you were voting
for a Town Council either you're voting
for specific seats with a term and you
know different terms or you might be
voting for like vote for three or
whatever I presume it's up to the town
in their
Charter further questions from the
committee representative
quae thank you
uh you just used the term Single
transferable vote is that defined in
actually and do realize that even though
there's multiple pages to this bill it's
all creating the concept of ranked
Choice voting the actual enacting piece
is um quite short it would probably yeah
undervote the lawyer in here may be able
to answer
better whether we use that actual term
or whether we just def we just describe
conducted I will say that single
transferable vote is currently is
actually the city of Cambridge uses it
to select their city council so it's
been technically speaking there are
several different flavors of single
transferable vote and the type we use is
the type that Scotland uses which is
called the Scottish Scottish
method thank you further questions from
the committee representative Lane
um because of the compressed amount of
time if we wanted to understand this a
little bit better is there a place you
can point us to um so that we could get
more information that you think is
simple enough to make us understand it
and other maybe our constituents so so
you mean just the concept of ring Tre
voting Fair vote is an amazing resource
they've assisted multiple places in the
country with um learning what rank
Choice voting is and adopting it in
education um Minnesota comes to mind as
a city that that they've assisted but um
certainly they've done it all over the
country so fair vot's an excellent
resource and of course we have our very
own New Hampshire rank Choice voting
which has a
website further questions from the
committee seeing thank you um next up is
Steven Bourne um we've got a couple of
cards here we're not too far behind on
schedule um because I did do a little
extra time with this uh but what I am
going to ask as an Indulgence for
members of the public please do not get
up here and explain how rank Choice
voting works the representatives get a
very good job of it so we don't need to
go through the mechanics of how it works
of like the concept but if you have like
why you like it or something specific
about it but this has been a an issue
with testimony on this bill in the past
is members of the public will get up and
just explain right choice voting again
and again and again and again it's like
so let's let's focus on what about it
you like specifically um and I I assume
at this point most of the members
understand the mechanics of it in terms
of the basically the immediate the
immediate runoff system um so if you
have questions like representative CAD
about logistics St like that totally
fair in in the game but as a as a matter
of testimony let's let's try to con
constrain it to why this is better and
not how it works if that makes
sense okay thank you stepen warrant from
Ry and I'd like to share with you why
I'd like the ability to have rank Choice
voting in our community totally great so
if you I assume you've all been
struggling with the table I gave you
last week and wondering what that 53%
number represented and I assume you've
all been staying up at night wondering
why more than half the people that
registered to vote in November at the
polls registered Undeclared so more than
half the people chose not to be
registered registered as a Democrat or
Republican and I'll give you you know
what's happening in our community one of
our friends was um was on the
conservation as an alternate the
committee had an open membership and he
decided to stand up and be a full-time
member he was attacked so viciously on
Facebook that he dropped out and we're
seeing more and more of this if you
start driving around now you'll start to
see them the March 11th campaign signs
come up they come up in little packs so
the house is either one of them or the
house is one of them and what's
happening for you got people like me and
plenty of others 40% of the state
neither of them
represent how we feel and our voice all
right so we've worked real hard in Ry to
get voter turn out the local election up
we've actually increased it by 50% we've
gone from just under 20% at just over
30% all right that still means about 70%
of the people aren't voting it's still a
lot better than what's happening in the
state primary which is just over 20%
move to September or June and maybe
watch it drop down to
15% all right one of the things that we
should all be able to agree to and all
work together is to address what I
believe is the biggest problem it's a
lack of participation and getting people
to choose to spend more time either vote
voting and participating especially at
the local level all right we're
struggling to get people to run now
because they're so afraid of being
associated with one side or the other
all right and so we're hoping that this
will give the opportunity that more
people will step up now I've been filing
online opposing and supporting the bills
that have been in front of this
committee most of them a lot of them are
solutions searching for a problem others
are things that are not going to make it
easier for people to participate and
that should be the thing that we all
should be working on together everything
that comes before this committee will it
help get more people to turn out and
vote more people to spend more of their
time to pay attention to all of our
government so what we're asking is
please give us the freedom to have the
option of having rank Choice voting in
our Community we have the new tabulators
I can't promise you it's going to get
more people to turn out and participate
but let's please try it
questions questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um next
up is
all and then on Deck is Kathleen begging
thank you chair um chair it's my first
time so if there's any process that I we
we are very kind and gentle go for it
okay um so first what I introduce myself
yep uh and pull that mic down just a
little bit because people at home have
everybody here in the room can hear you
but people at home are watching okay hi
my name is kishma mser I'm from exitor
New
Hampshire um across the country we see
that candidates can ignore the will of
most voters and still win elections
politics is tearing our society apart
because elections aren't working for
most of us and many American voters are
increasingly frustrated with partisan
toxic politics rank Choice voting will
promote less negative campaigning while
giving voters access to candidates with
a broader range of ideas let me tell you
a personal story I participated in a
town election where most voters
preferred one of two highly qualified
candidates were well-regarded members of
the community most voters did not prefer
the Third candidate who was running a
divisive negative
campaign sadly the third candidate ended
up winning with only 34% of the total
votes the other two candidates as I
mentioned who were preferred by most
voters lost due to due to split voting
with each getting about 33% of the total
votes so similar to many other elections
the winner did not win as the choice of
the absolute majority but one because of
plurality in this town election the
option for rank Choice voting would have
given voters the freedom to select a
backup choice hb600 as all of you know
is only an enabling bill it will allow
municipalities like mine to ask voters
whether they want to opt in for our
local Municipal elections our choice to
optin would not affect any other
municipality thank you okay and would
you like to take questions from the
committee sure are there questions from
the committee so be nice be nice all
right thank you so so much thank you uh
next up is Kathleen bean and then on
Coleman hello my name is Kathleen Bean
I'm from bruntwood New Hampshire and I
will be um very brief um again this is
also my first time doing this so um I
just want to you know give my support
for um giving the towns the option to
ADT rank Choice voting um it you know it
promotes political competition and
engagement across a diverse um spectrum
of political beliefs
um the bill supports um principle of
local control and opt in and gives
voters more
choice and therefore more of a voice um
in their elected officials um
it does away with strategic voting where
people are you know feeling like um they
need to vote against a candidate um it
lets voters vote their
conscience
um it levels the playing field gives
more people you know um an opportunity
um and it ures that voters are electing
candidates with the most voter support
as others have stated
um because rank Choice voting opens up a
greater competition of ideas um giving
constitutes a deeper more nuanced
expression of their real preferences um
I would say politics aside that's
something that we can all support thank
you for letting me speak okay and would
you like to take any
questions um no thank
awesome they say there's no right answer
but there is a right answer uh next up
Tiani X Coleman and then Kaye estadio
fine
all
right good afternoon honorable members
of the election law committee my name is
Tiani Coleman and I'm from Amherst New
Hampshire I testify today in support of
hb600 FN enabling rank Choice voting for
Municipal elections on behalf of myself
and on behalf as president of of New
Hampshire rank Choice voting a
nonpartisan nonprofit organization
composed 100% of Citizen
volunteers I've provided three handouts
to the committee one is the testimony
that has been submitted online of
Republican Josh Daniels a former Utah
County Clerk who administered rank
Choice voting for numerous
municipalities when Utah First adopted a
local option Bill two reasons to support
hb600
three uh a detail with a few graphs on
how RCV Works in single winner and
multi-winner elections as well as a
sample ballot using chocolate sample
rank Choice voting ballot so please
review these as well as the online
testimony of Deb Otis of fair vote where
she cites numerous exit polls and
studies on the successes of rank Choice
voting and read please the thoughtful
online statements in support of this
bill by hundreds of New Hampshire
citizens hb600 is a simple Pro Liberty
Bill that should not be controversial
and should have overwhelming near
unanimous support it won't cost the
state a dime it doesn't mandate anything
on anyone hb600 simply enables local
local municipalities to determine how to
best meet their needs in their own local
Municipal elections such as mayor
council select board clerk moderator Etc
the only thing this bill does is give
towns and cities permission to have an
RCV ballot
measure if the bill passes nothing
changes unless and until a town or city
proposes and passes a warrant article or
local ballot measure opting in to using
RCV for Municipal elections only one
town or city has no effect on another
town or city small towns may not have a
need for this but others do let's let
towns decide some cities want to save
money in their local elections by using
rank Choice voting instead of runoff
elections some towns would benefit from
having more proportional represent
representation and multi-winner races so
that all people from the various
factions in town feel
represented I first learned about rank
Choice voting in 2002 serving in the
Republican party in Utah where we used
RCV in convention for a 12 candidate us
Congressional race and for an eight
candidate gubernatorial race in 2004
voters liked rank Choice liked ranking
candidates and the candidates felt like
it was
fair Josh Daniels who I referred to he
shows how easy the process was to
implement and administer in
municipalities in a county of about
350,000 registered voters a very
conservative County studies show that
voters find arv easy to understand and
use election results for rank Choice
voting can be instant especially in a
municipal election rank Choice voting
has very low error rates can be handc
counted is fully transparent and can be
audited and recounted without incident
the experience of County clerks all
around the country where rank Choice
voting has been implemented is similar
to what Josh Daniels explains at first
they're worried they don't want it they
think it's going to be a disaster and
then they always find out it's easy
simple it runs without a hitch and then
they become a big
fan uh Salt Lake County has Salt Lake
County also used rank Choice voting and
they had instant results the night of
the election as the as the results were
coming in it automatically showed the
results and not just like the final
numbers but you can see the full results
um exactly where the votes are going in
each round it's really awesome um RCB
we've already said it's reaching 51
American jurisdictions it's home to
nearly nearly 14 million voters in the
US that includes two Statewide uses
three countywide uses 46 Citywide uses
that have already been used plus many
more coming this year next year um
military and overseas voters use it in
Six States in one city um there there's
no worry about voter and administrator
education there are a lot of great
groups out there that will fully educate
for free the voters and the people who
need to administer the elections it's
very simple uh so rain choice voting is
fully constitutional it's been tested in
the courts it's been tested many places
as I said in uh Deb Otis's testimony she
talks about how big countries for years
have been hand counting rank Choice
voting it's very easy um it encourages
competition healthy competition without
the problem of vote splitting and it
ensures that everyone's vote matters and
that the candidate with the most support
wins I'm happy to answer any questions
about how rank Choice voting works or
about election Administration or where
it's used or the results of the exit
polls and the studies that have been
done okay other questions from the
committee representative Lane thank you
for taking my question
um when you go beyond the first round
can you explain like everybody can see
those that's pretty
transparent what happens when if you
have to go to the second round I mean
you said can you just is it transparent
does it happen like in the voting box I
mean what happens yes um the when the
okay so there's different ways to do it
once again the towns can decide uh which
offices they're going to use it for and
all of that so if you have a machine
that is able to do it it will tabulate
it um as as representative Reed said you
do need to centralize it if you get to
the rank Choice vote but you don't need
to centralize it to start with you the
machine runs the first count exactly the
way the counts are used now and you
often can get a winner just from those
first counts um if you need to run the
rounds then you do need to centralize
all you do is centralize a little uh a
little drive that's in the machine but
the memory still stays with the machine
and the ballot still stay in in the
place where they started and then you
centralize it to you just centralize it
to the town clerk or the town moderator
and you be you can run that drive
through a software that is open source
completely open you can see exactly
what's happening and then it C it
produces a cast vote record so you
actually get a more complete picture of
what has happened in the election than
we do now um it's not it's obviously of
course Anonymous you don't know who
voted how but you do know how every
voter cast their their rankings and you
can see exactly how the rankings worked
and you know during your break we will
we can do a chocolate election with the
ballot that you have and and tabulate it
right here in front of you and you can
see how how it works in each
round okay okay further questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you um next
estadio thank you chairman brry and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Kaye of stadio I am a public
policy fellow with open democracy and a
voter I just have um very brief
testimony to read today from Karen Dodge
of Derry New
Hampshire um she says as a New Hampshire
constituent and voter I am asking you to
support
hb600 as you know this bill does not
require any New Hampshire city or town
to adopt a ring Choice voting system but
rather enables the citizens of New
Hampshire municipalities to use the
system for local elections if they so
choose if you believe that local
elections should be run by local
government with the approval of the
secretary of State you should not be
afraid to vote in support of this bill
my understanding is that ring Choice
voting serves to encourage increased
voter participation as Citizens start to
realize that their vote does count and
to discourage negative campaigning by
candidates in the hopes of gaining
secondary Choice status from voters the
most important reason that I support
rank Choice voting is that the winner of
Elections has the support of the
majority of Voters this is a nonpartisan
Bill and has bipartisan support please
support
hb600 and I won't be taking questions
love it all right next up is last up is
Olivia
zinc good afternoon for the record my
name is Olivia zinc a voter in Franklin
executive director of open democracy um
and open democracy is a nonpartisan
nonprofit Pro voter organization um and
um the last I looked was December of
2022 rank Choice voting um was reaching
um 60 2 American jurisdictions and over
3 million voters in this country um two
states two counties and 58 cities or
Municipal elections um and overseas and
Military voters use rank Choice voting
in Six States Cambridge Massachusetts
has used rank Choice voting since
1941 successfully for their city council
and their school committees uh rank
Choice voting is very nonpartisan it
gives voters more choices and a greater
voice at the poll under this system you
rank your preferences um and it's it's
really a voids candidates people who
vote for the you know I don't like this
guy so I'm going to vote for the other
person and a lot of Voters go to the
poll and vote vote that way um I'll just
and it also um is a solution to voter a
apathy um I'll just tell one quick story
with the first time I ran for City
Council in the city of Franklin there
were three candidates for city council I
think I won because the other you know
the other two got more votes than I did
but I won by 17 votes because I was the
top vote
getter um rank Choice voting does
decrease
polarization um because when you're
talking to voters maybe you're not their
first choice but you could say could I
be your second choice and you could
gives you a chance to introduce yourself
and also uh less confrontational and
less negative at uh Campa aing um I'm
sure you've heard uh lots of Voters that
are sick and tired of negative ads
during campaign season and rank Choice
voting does result in more positive
campaigns in the jurisdictions where
it's used um rank Choice voting um is
possible for you to pick you know two
Republicans or or the Democrat and and
rank the other candidates most of the
local elections are
nonpartisan um
and I think it this also just is a
opt-in and allows local communities to
do this and it also will give voters um
more confidence in their elections thank
you for your time and I won't take
questions it's great it's great day okay
it thank you for recognizing me again Mr
chair the question that was asked
earlier was is single transferable vote
mentioned I think in a previous
iteration of the bill this is like my
10th version of this bill um we did but
in this version it is only described not
named uh on page four lines 17 through
27 that paragraph that's labeled B
lowercase B that paragraph describes the
method of Scottish version of single
transferable vote page 4 17- 27 and with
that I'll end I'll just say rank Choice
voting is the highest definition picture
of the will of the
electorate okay and with that we will
close the public hearing for House Bill
600 uh on the blue sheet was five in
support zero opposed online with 664 in
support 33 opposed and zero neutral uh
with that we will open the executive
executive whoa uh the public hearing of
House Bill 412 relative to elections and
appointments to fill vacancies of local
Cooperative school districts and
representative SP I was say I knew I saw
you on the bill but I didn't see your
card there we go uh we'll recognize Rec
representative spillsbury for the
introduction thank you very much Mr
chairman um my first visit with the
election law
committee so this bill 412 has two
purposes Associated to each other by
virtue of the fact that both of them
deal with the composition of a school
board in a Cooperative School
District uh these proposals were in
bills that last year went to the
education committee went to interim
study and uh were recommended for future
legislation in the education committee
last
fall what they do is very simple the
explanation of why they're needed
perhaps take a little bit more time
first you'll see on line 16 and
17 that if a district has made the
decision to allocate seats on the school
board by town or by prior
District this is saying that they have
to be elected exclusively within their
own
District so for example I represent uh
Charlestown Unity Newport Newport has
its own School District simple no
problems Charles toown is a member of
the Fall Mountain Regional School
District Five
Towns seven member School Board two
seats at large one allocated to each
Town each prior
District there's um quite a dispersion
of student population amongst those
towns Charlestown has 46% % wall pole
about 30
32% and then three towns together make
up the balance two of which are
extremely small but each Town gets one
seat and in Fall Mountain district and
I've learned uh since developing this
bill uh in in many other districts the
uh Charles Town seat is elected by all
the voters of the district all five
towns
the little tiny towns aworth or langon
have their member elected from the
entire District that creates some very
anomalous results essentially the larger
towns can tell the smaller towns who
their their representative is going to
be but even in the case of Charlestown
several times in the last half dozen
years the uh voters of Charlestown in a
contested election choose candidate a
and the other four towns represent sing
5% of the AG 55% of the aggregate vote
select somebody different so I I think
the the first part of the bill is simply
to ensure that the town gets the town's
voters get to choose their own
representative and not have that outcome
driven by the other towns in the
district the second part of the bill
which you'll find on lines 26 to
28 uh is a little more nuanced in and
what that says is that in a Cooperative
School District that has outlar
seats when a member holding an atlarge
seat resigns midterm and the vacancy is
to be filled which I understand
generally it's certainly true in Fall
Mountain is is filled by the remaining
members of the school
board this amendment says that the
candidates that they can choose from and
the candidate they appoint has to come
from the same town as the doile of the
um of the member who has just resigned
who whose position is being filled the
purpose of that is again to maintain the
dynamic balance of a board so where you
have a board again using using Fall
Mountain as an example where every every
town regardless of its size is uh is
assigned one
seat the importance of the outlar seats
is that they tend to maintain a a
balance and typically uh the Electoral
Dynamics in that District are that one
atlarge seat is held by a Charlestown
representative and one by a Walpole
representative and that at least does a
partial
rebalancing but when one of those
atlarge members
resigns the remaining school board
members who are predominantly from other
towns
um I have found empirically often are
tempted to appoint uh whoever they're
you know closest comrade is and that's
often somebody who was defeated in a
prior election there have been all kinds
of weird efforts to shift the balance
away from the town that has the dominant
population uh towards uh others so uh
two different bills uh that have been
combined into one if you have uh
reservations um I am happy to help
fashion an amendment if you decide that
you like one of these proposals and
you're uncomfortable with the other
please split them and uh Advance the one
that you uh ear in consensus on I'm glad
to take any questions all right are
there questions from the committee
representative
Lane thank you for taking my question
this is something that's a little out of
our realm you know so
U I think the educ ation policy and
administration committee was surprised
that it didn't go to them but you're the
lucky one Municipal in County you know
who knows um it it seems to me that if
you're giving the smallest town I think
you mentioned aworth the same
number the same voice that you're giving
Charlestown which has
46% that seems a bit disproportional to
me in making decisions if they are I'm
assuming not putting in as much money
and they don't have as many students but
yet they're they're getting more of a
voice than perhaps well I would agree
with you and in in that example aworth
which has about seven or eight% of the
students has the same uh voice as
Charles down with 46 these are historic
anomalies that have derived from the
formation of districts in the case of
Fall Mountain
1966 that was part of the bargain of
bringing the communities together and um
I think it would be an interesting topic
to completely reexamine that but it is
also a function of the Articles of
agreement and what I'm trying to do is
accept that history but temper the worst
Temptations for the guest representative
Lane
followup again thank
you
um I I'll never mind
all right further questions from the
committee seeing n thank you
representative spillsbury only have one
Horan I'm representing Timothy Horan
straford County District 10 which is the
town of Durham which not and I mention
before that's the largest town in the
Oyster River Cooperative School District
so um we have I think roughly two-thirds
of the population and
although Lee and Madbury both are well
represented in the school boards
proceedings obviously Durham has a
disproportionate influence and that's
not entirely inappropriate we're
democracy we have more people than the
others and uh luckily although there's a
lot of difference opinions how to run
the school district among the people
it's not necessarily geographically
concentrated one town or another and we
have one fairly small town uh which is
Madbury although it's about 5% of the
population um so it's but there are
other much smaller towns in Madbury that
are part of Cooperative school districts
uh well the smallest incorporate towns
heart location and I think it's
elsewhere don't seem to have Cooperative
school districts they just have their
own school district and tuition to
neighboring communities but like
Roxberry population 20 20 which is the
third largest town in the state is part
of the manad school district the orange
which is the fifth smallest community in
the state is a part of the masoma Valley
School District which I'm familiar with
because I used to work in Enfield which
is where the masoma Valley High School
is and used to live in the next town
over in in Lebanon and um and they have
uh I know the case of masoma Valley they
have members from all five towns in the
district um including orange which is
very small and Grafton which is not much
bigger and um so if there was a
vacancy and somebody happened to live in
or Grafton or Kanan um no not Kanan is
not really the problem but but
Orange um they would have to find
somebody else from that exact town be
whether it be Grafton or or orange and
the population of the towns is so small
there may not necessarily be anybody
who's interested in serving on the
school board or anybody
who's qualified doing the school board
amongst the PO population of the towns
they might have a hard time finding
someone suitable to a point um and that
would be even worse if some place as
small as Hearts location happened to be
in a Cooperative School District which
happily for the purpose of the bill
they're not so the thing in so part
second part of the bill line 26 to 28 uh
if you move forward with it um you would
probably have to have some sort of a
fallback position for if nobody actually
wants to be on the school board in those
towns um and uh and also the first part
of it was the problem with an early Bill
talked about you could get into huge one
person one point votes if you do that
for example like our the charter the
oyer of school district Le in uh Madbury
I think they're guaranteed a seat in the
school district so if only the voters in
Madbury were voting they'd have about uh
you know you'd have a population
deviation of I don't know like 40,000
per or something way above the pl
standard Plus orus 5% or plus or minus
10% so that's just U so that's a big
problem with with both of these things
and I don't know how often it's
necessary usually yeah as I said usually
the educational needs of the smaller
towns are similar to those of the larger
towns so there isn't usually necessarily
be that much geographical dissension and
if there is you know it's difficult but
is possible to split the Cooperative
School District into you know smaller
pieces so I would just say uh they'll
probably it's probably not worth moving
forward with it and if it do you
obviously you're going to want to like
retain it and you know tweak the
language of it even if you like the idea
behind the bill so I just think it's
problematic so I would if I was on the
committee I and an not to pass came by I
would probably vote no on it but so
thanks I'd be happy to take any
questions if anybody has are there
questions from the committee yeah seeing
none thank that I can answer them but
thank no worries all right with that we
will close the public hearing for House
Bill 412 there was no one on the blue
sheet and online it was I don't know why
it 412 online no we're
okay on that that expense uh there's one
in support 13 opposed one neutral um
when I loaded it up it said there was
600 in support it's just it's a lot of
some glitch because that was a I'm glad
I D I'm glad I made it refresh because
there was not that much traffic on the
bill um okay uh we're going to close
412 and we will open up the public
hearing on House Bill 429 relative to
amending the term length of County
Commissioners
is Barton okay uh is Mr Barton or Mr
damus here m m delus here no uh res
toner can you do the old uh do the old
introduction
representative toner um like to I'm from
belnap 4 beln town of bmap um Belmont um
like to introduce House Bill 429 and I
will not be taking questions it's the
best introduction all right we will
start off with our own representative
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
members I'll be very brief I do not
support HB
429 uh and I'll explain quickly why we
are varied across the state north to
south east to
west last year Coos County uh put a bill
in the delegation to change our elected
officials our uh Register of Deeds our
Sheriff our Treasurer our County
attorney to go from a two-year term to a
four-year term because we felt it was
very important to have some continuity
and we thought we could attract better
uh candidates for those positions it
passed it was signed so that's the way
is it is in coas County we never assumed
that it was going to be the best for
every
County right now the I am the co-chair
of the delegation we have a very good
working relationship with our County
Commissioners um we have no issues we'd
like to keep this the system the same
and the biggest thing is having
continuity and having the uh terms being
a little bit longer that twoyear to
four-year
term uh I would suggest if the sponsor
of the bill is having problems his
County put a bill in to change your
county but to have something widespread
across the state uh because you're
having a problem isn't in my opinion the
solution thank you will you be taking
questions from the committee yes I will
are there questions from the
representative
Gilmore is there any other County that
has a four-year term from what I
understand Rockingham does okay thank
you
um okay seeing um the only thing about
this is not really related to the bill
but something to note is when they adopt
these fouryear especially for the County
Commissioners when they adopt these
four-year
um uh terms it does create headaches in
redistricting because their district
will change while they're serving um and
it creates legal questions um but that's
not that that's not relative to the to
the bill just something
to when when other counties are
considering this you have to consider
the math and it's impossible to get it
to work because there's 10 year 10 years
every ring and foure intervals it
doesn't work um anyways uh next up is
representative Timothy Horan sorry I
just felt the need to Aline that has
bill yep so I'm continu to be represent
Timothy Oregon from straford County
District 10 the town of Durham and
straford County was the county that
originally till few years ago didn't
have any County Commissioner District
but that's not really affected by this
bill so the um this bill of course
probably should have been a municipal
and County government and actually they
had a the the two sponsors had a bill
about the Grafton County Commission
which uh well they didn't show actually
show up to introduce the bill but it got
a lot of opposition from Grafton County
and Statewide but that uh that's
Municipal and County government's
problem so they um and also so it's
fairly unlikely as far as you know
there's any support in Grafton County or
any other County you know for making all
the county commissioner terms two years
a number of counties do have fouryear
terms for County
Commission um so there's doesn't seem to
be any public outcry for this so there
and also even you know even if you
decide you like the idea want to move
forward with it the way it's
uh the way it's drafted I think it's
problematic you could probably just do
the whole thing by one line by just
saying all County Commissioners have
two-year terms it might need a little
bit more detail to deal with the
existing fouryear terms but uh that
could probably be done much more simply
than having this list a through I which
by the way is not in any discernable
order so like you know Hillsboro Carol
straford ends with Coos and Grafton so I
have no idea why they why it's in that
order although that's a problem with
other Law related to County
Commissioners so I I would say uh this
is a I say this is a fundamentally
unnecessary Bill and even if I'm wrong
and it is NE necessary uh you could take
those 23 lines and combine them into two
or three and have a much you know much
cleaner uh you know much cleaner much
cleaner way of doing it especially if
might get com especially if if straford
County goes back at some point in the
future to have an at llarge District or
if any other county is an at llarge
District the language of here would
probably kind of break whereas if you
just want to say all County
Commissioners have two-year districts
that's you should probably just say that
but I think I think you should leave the
law alone because there's no support for
far as I know there's no support for
changing any of the existing four-year
County Commissioners terms back to two
years except by the sponsors who for
whatever reason are not even here and
weren't here for another related bill
that they had in mpal and County
government so I I I would I'd urge you
to uh itl this bill and thanks have any
I have any questions you can try to I
can answer them maybe questions from the
committee s none thank you uh next up is
shli I I I hit him with speaker which is
better than honor one missed that is
speaker because I believe you get the
title for Life yeah that's what they
tell me you got to grab the mic yeah H
that it's a Life Time title I don't know
if there's any analogy between me being
here and a thief returning to the scene
of the crme
but um but it's a pleasure to see you
all I'm going to follow my friend from
Stewartstown in my brev for the record
my name is Steve sherle from a uh
resident of Ward one of conquer the
village of Penacook and last November
after 20 years in the house I was
elected to Marram County Commission and
having spent 20 years going to County
delegation meetings I felt being elected
as a commissioner I knew everything I
needed to know uh through that and uh as
soon as I got elected I realized how
much which I didn't know and I've been
very fortunate I happen to be a Democrat
my two other Commissioners are
Republicans and they have they have
become friends but even more so they've
become mentors to me along with our
outstanding County uh
employees I'm going I'm going to end
right there but I'm just going to say
I'm sure the sponsors of this Bill had a
good intention but apparently it seems
to be a solution to a problem that just
doesn't exist and I would ask this
committee to please to uh Lo itl and I'd
be glad to take any questions Mr
chairman okay are there questions seeing
none and and welcome back to the state
house thank you very much uh next up is
Raymond
Horan so Raymond Gorman my hometown is
corob New Hampshire I'm a county
commissioner in KS County for District 3
my District's a a large District it
starts at the southern end of the county
at Carroll up to gorm and then I have we
start we switch over and we have all the
rest of the northern my district is the
Pittsburgh cber stewartown Etc I think I
have 18 unincorporated towns um so our
county is the unincorporated towns adds
a whole another element to County
government we're selecting for all those
communities the 20 plus count uh
unincorporated towns
what it takes to learn I was fortunate
that my first term I'm now on my second
term was a four-year term and I I was
came in in 2020 I had Co so my first
year was a lost year spent on a computer
screen and there's a learning curve to
be an a county commissioner and it's I
think that the continuity is is
something that we really need to talk
about here is to have at least one
commissioner there after each election
that has experience all right it's
worked well in Coos um we have two
nursing homes as well and it it just
there's no need to change this uh the
work that our my the folks did last year
with the county treasur sheriff Etc like
that was well received and well
supported so uh we weren't looking for
any changes on the county commissioner
level at that time and are absolutely
not looking for any changes today um
pretty simple uh I can get into more
details if you like and be glad to
answer any questions other questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
Horan representative gasowski if you
could grab that uh is that written
testimony it is I I'm bad I didn't do it
correctly it's all right we we we won't
hold it against you too much apologies
Mr chair my name is Kate Horan uh
representing the New Hampshire
Association of counties and I am pinch
hitting for commissioner Tom Morell from
Rockingham County the uh afternoon he
apologizes he had a electrician job that
he got called to um so he did uh ask me
to step in and offer testimony on behalf
of the association the association is
opposed to this bill there are eight
counties that currently have a four-year
float the Commissioners did a great job
talking about continuity uh commissioner
Tom Bell did ask me to highlight
Rockingham County in particular
Rockingham County does not have a County
Administrator that runs the day-to-day
operation operations the Commissioners
run the day-to-day operations in
Rockingham County um so having that
floating four-year term is really
important right now they're in the
middle of a very large building project
that is happening that is going to house
deeds in the Sheriff's Office and a
couple other County facilities um and
having someone there after each election
while they're going through this
construction process is extremely
important to them uh so the association
ask that you uh itl the bill and I'm
happy to take any questions okay other
questions from the committee seeing done
thank you um onl I don't have any more
pink cards online there was two in
support 10 opposed uh on the blue sheet
was zero in support and one opposed not
speaking and with that we will close the
public hearing for House Bill uh
429 and we will stand in recess until
House Bill 333 but I have a statement I
want to make uh because this has come up
a couple times today election law is
section is uh section 63 of the New
Hampshire RSA it covers every RSA
chapter 252 to 27 chapter 2 652 to 671
so anything in there is election law and
we a couple times today people said I
don't know why this bill is an election
law you're literally amending an RSA
where the title of the chapter is Town
elections so it is most certainly in our
purview please committee members stop
trying to give away our Authority we
have that entire section
652 all the way to 671 if you if you
amend that section it's coming to us and
e
okay it's house build it's house Billo
it's 2:10 it's time for House Bill 333
going to open the public hearing for
House Bill 333 requiring moderators to
designate a space for election nearing
at polling places and provide a
schematic uh thereof and I will repr
recognize representative Rich Neno for
the purpose of
introduction welcome to election law we
haven't seen you yet this year right uh
yes that's correct there you go so good
afternoon chairman Barry and members of
the election law committee thank you for
your time today my name is Rich alvano
and I represent chesher District 9 which
includes the towns of elstead Gilson
Marlo and St
uh I should add that uh while I'm a
first term uh legislator and I should
you know ask for some latitude because
I'm still filling my way around on uh
the processes and the rules uh but I'm
also a six or seven time who counting a
candidate for office so I have some
experience related to this subject and
uh I'm sure everybody in this uh uh
committee room as well as everybody in
the legislature has
I'm here to introduce House Bill 333 as
the prime sponsor before I start my
comments on the bill before you I'd like
to commend the committee for its ongoing
work to ensure overall election
Integrity which is vital to maintaining
a vibrant Democratic Republic a key part
of your committee is balancing two
important and sometimes competing
interests protecting the rights of
Voters to be able to access polling
places free of harassment or
intimidation while at the same time
uphold holding the First Amendment right
of free speech afforded to candidates
for public office who desire to provide
information at polling places on
Election Day to interested voters to
quote Thomas Jefferson an informed
citizen is at the heart of a dynamic
democracy unquote while the existing
of candidates is required to restore
balance in the law H Bill b House Bill
333 is a straightforward and necessary
intention of the underlying statute this
is particularly important in communities
primarily in rural areas such as those
in my district that often change polling
places in years when there is a pres
Presidential
Election House Bill 333 is a simple
Common Sense solution that improves
transparency and accountability and
clarifies access for candidates and the
voting public to our polling places
preserves First Amendment protections to
all involved and reduces confusion that
has previously led to contentious
situations between poll workers public
officials candidates campaign volunteers
and the public at
large it will have the it will have the
added benefit of aiding the oversight
responsibilities of the Secretary of
State and reducing complaints I would
add that here is essentially little or
no cost of implementing House Bill
333 uh I would also add I have a written
testimony which I'll leave on the uh
table but I also add that I've had uh
discussions with the Secretary of State
both before I drafted the uh original uh
legislation and actually before I came
in here uh to testify today and um the
secretary of state has really no
objections or problems with the bill as
written um I would be happy to I'm also
going to leave a copy of an interesting
article um on uh entitled the role of
the moderator as an election official
and this is reprinted with the
permission of the New Hampshire bar
journal and the New Hampshire Bar
Association and I think I found it very
educational um uh in spite of I what I
thought I knew about the various roles
of election officials so I I only have
one copy of that I'll leave it if
anybody's interested um be happy to
arrange uh additional copies but to
quote from that because I've also
consulted with uh people who are
moderators I've tried to do my homework
on this uh subject matter and there's a
quote in here that's kind of interesting
and uh one of the objections that I
heard from a moderator in my own
delegation was that gee you know
moderators you're just trying to load
some more um things for a moderator to
do and moderators are uh uh busy as it
is on on day there's an interesting
quote in this article that says quote on
the local level the city or town clerks
the Selectmen City councils or their
counterparts and the supervisors of the
checklist have far more to do and far
more rules to follow in the conduct of
an election than does the moderator it
is overly simplistic but not entirely
inaccurate to say that the moderator
shows up on the morning of the election
prior to the opening of the polls stays
most of the day except unless he
appoints a moderator proem for a time
when he's absent from the polling place
to eat lunch or to attend to his
horses uh and remains after the close of
the voting until the results of any
elections which are determined by the
district which the moderator supervisors
have been determined and announced by
the moderator since a moderator cannot
by law serve as a selectman town treasur
truste of trust funds collector of taxes
Highway agent or supervisor of the
checklist he or she is unlikely to have
any other significant official interest
in the election process and I read that
only to kind of um um address what I
suspect are you know the objections of
people that are moderators about being
overloaded with
work
um so um I'd be happy to answer any
questions I urge this committee to
support a recommendation of autopass OTP
for house pill
333 and thank you on behalf of everyone
committed to improving election
uh laws in our state uh respectfully
submitted uh Rich noveno chesher n okay
and will you be taking questions
representative yes sir I guess that's
yes representative
wood thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for taking my question um what I've been
finding I've haven't uh tried to run as
often as you have two elections so far
and what I find is there's a breakdown
uh in our problems um the we have the
people running and the people who are
voting or just there uh we have a
conflict very very strong conflict in
enforcement between the First Amendment
rights and someone running uh the a
candidate running seems to be a whole
different setting do you see is this
address what problem is this
addressing well it's it's it's
fundamentally addressing a number and
I've run U um as I said six or seven
times
and have run into various insundry
situations where it's not clear as I
said one problem is uh that elections in
small towns tend to shift their voting
Place uh between the presidential year
and the off year simply because the size
of the electorate that turns out is
different one one year it may be in in
our case of one of the small towns in
our district it's held at the Town Hall
in the presidential year it's held at a
at a school um um and uh new candidates
especially and I would point out that I
think on average the uh House of
Representatives body turns over about
30% of the 30% of the uh uh people in
office uh every two years and so you
have a lot of new people who are new to
the process and they're trying to F out
and it would be helpful to everybody to
have Clarity on you know where I'm
voting what the what the overall
physical layout is where I'm where I'm
allowed to be where I'm not allowed to
be and I found over you know over the
several years some moderators or towns
in this case do a great job of marking
out with tape on the ground and where
you can visibly see the corridor that's
provided uh in terms of protecting
access unimpeded access by people going
to the polls uh and also electioneering
and I will also point out that the
underlying law has specific requirements
for um the the candidates in terms of
being able to reach the electorate
without interfering with access in a
normal speaking voice um and in I I
could name several situations where um
even though the area wasn't marked out
the moderator would come out and say
this is the area that I'm quote
designating for campaigning and that
that is what the uh uh change in the
legislation uh designate us a little bit
uh fuzzy language when I looked up the
uh the the dictionary definition so
somebody verbally designating it
satisfies the language the way it
currently sits on the other hand
designate and the clarification is hey
Mark it out so it's clear nobody has any
uh objection as to where it is and
that's the clar the clarity uh part of
the addition into this uh RSA so there
are addition I've had a case where a
moderator told me uh I said up you know
there was nothing marked out I went to
set up a table to campaign the moderator
came out and literally said to me nope
you can't be there you've got to be a
thousand yards from the school and I
looked at him and I said that can't be
right uh uh and a thousand yards would
have put me down on Route 10 and that's
you know and he and the case I've been
the moderator for 20 years and I know
what the rules are and I said please go
get the rule book while he was away I
called the Secretary of State's hotline
and I at that time I think uh uh Mr
scanland was the Assistant Attorney
General now the Attorney General he
picked up the picked up the
phone ises he
here oh yeah okay so so if I'm speak if
you yeah I got him on the line while the
guy was gone and explained the situation
and he said please put him on the line
and I'll I'll I'll sort him out which
quite uh uh I would say to his credit
didn't take very much uh very much time
for him to sort it out but still uh that
resulted in uh kind of intimidating
candidates nobody showed up at that
particular polling place over several
Cycles because the word got around that
the you know the moderator wasn't you
know was going to put him someplace and
didn't want to go through the hassle so
that's a long-winded I I don't know if
I've answered your question but there
are a lot of and there are some safety
issues as well uh we had I had people
helping with my campaign who were
literally in the town of stod put down
uh in an area right alongside Route
123 and every time a truck came by it
kind of you know moved the uh moved the
volunteers anyhow so there are a whole
host of ISU issues that would I think
help to spell out things in a manner
that everybody understood clearly what
uh what the rules the RS uh called for
so is that more than sufficient to
answer your question you're welcome all
right further questions from the
committee representative C thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh my concern is you want this
done within five days of the end of the
filing period but the town may not have
actually finalize where they're having
the election or other aspects of the
building that the election is going to
be held in uh it would seem like this
ought to be within five days of the
election
occurring well I I think I I would I
think I would disagree that most towns
know where they're going to where
they're going to hold the election and
mostly it has to do with a uh an
assessment of you know it's an offe
election or if they have a particularly
contentious issue on the local ballot
and we had that case anoun it a number
of years ago where uh what was driving
the turna was a totally uh local issue
and the town realized that well in
advance and uh changed the location uh
so I don't think that that's a
particular issue unless you know of some
specific
example so they usually know well in
advance where they're going to hold the
election I can actually name example
represented gusowski when he ran into
his special we didn't know where the
voting location was going to be um so it
actually it actually does happen uh
represent Nome thank you thank you for
taking the question um do you think that
the Thousand fine will have a chilling
effect on people running for moderator
now and I discussed this with uh When I
Was preparing the bill and doing my
homework so uh um the reason that's in
there one of the things and and from
experience and I I won't go into a lot
of the detail one of the things as
legislators that we have to be conscious
of when we write legislation and i' I've
run into this numerous times we pass the
legislation we don't
specify uh either what the penalty you
know have a penalty provision in the law
and then furthermore we don't specify
who's responsible for enforcement and so
when I was going through with the uh
uh what is it the office office of uh
legislative services or whatever the
suggestion was that the and that by the
way the language says up to a thousand
and so my my uh expectation is is that
there would be discretion exercised and
you know normally I wouldn't I wouldn't
think you'd run into a situation where
you'd be required to have the uh
penalty U enforced unless it was really
an egregious situation and I think I
would rely on the Judgment of uh people
enforcing this provision to be sensible
about it so it doesn't specify that it
would be a thousand it says up to and
that's all the way from zero uh you know
to sorting it out uh amicably without a
fine to any m in between zero and a
thousand so I don't think it uh um
necessarily has a chilling effect but it
does have a provision in there that uh
says hey um you know you can ignore you
can ignore the law and not have any
consequence does that answer your
question it does but it's still a major
concern of mine that's all as a as
somebody who's been a school moderator
for 10 years this would have a chilling
effect on me and I would ALS well it's
not a I don't have a question there
sorry sorry chair it's it's school
vacation week things are happening um
uh you know I'm taking questions from
the
there um further questions from the
committee oh see that was you I don't
know that was you um seeing done thank
you uh next up is representative Timothy
Horan
thank you very much I'm represent
Timothy Horus Rafford County District 10
and actually this is the uh last bill
I'm planing the testify in you probably
like see more than more than enough for
me but I always enjoy coming to election
law this was my first committee I served
on uh now ninth I like now in my ninth
term actually hard to time time flies
when you're having fun but anyway the
I'm not sure the anecdote about R nalo
being told he had to be a th feet away
from the Ping place that coincidentally
is uh the radius specified in the
federal gunfree schools act so I don't
know whether that anything to do why the
moderate okay um so that's that may or
may not have anything anything to do
with it um probably if you want to look
at that andic do it more detail you
probably to have a work session and try
to sort out exactly what it is that the
moderator said if you can figure it out
and but um this issue been near dear to
my heart well recently because I had the
gunfree poing place bill which was uh
turned down well basically on party
lines a few Democrat five Democrats
crossed over and uh so it went down
to ignominious defeat and um did not go
to this committee but rather criminal
justice so that's uh that's a subject
I've been thinking about hopefully and
um in that particular one I limited my
bill just to the 100 foot radius
traditional 100 foot radius around the
Ping place out which is where the
electioneering is um not supposed to
take place so that's sort been the been
the custom and this pill uh one of the
reason I did that was just to you know
simplify simplify things for gun owners
who might even be choosing
electioneer um it is you do occasionally
see a candidate who feels the need to
open carry his fire his or her firearm
at the poing place which luckily doesn't
happen too often because it
really doesn't gain you any votes you
know you you you probably can only lose
votes by like wearing a gun in a place
where people you might have some voters
who don't like their candidate open
carrying a gun at a place where you
usually don't see guns such as at the
local school so that's um and that's
something a
moderator might actually need to think
about that might be the moderator
certainly threatening or harassing um
voters you know shouldn't be allowed at
poing place with even with the
electioneering era though though I
suppose if it's being carried out if the
person's wearing a gun then he gets
Second Amendment issues so that top of
all the First Amendment issues and
everything else so U the uh so I I think
it looks like this definitely would be
an unfunded mandate the cost may be
minimal but I think they would be
nonzero because they have to draw up
this plan they have to post it on the
website submitted to the Secretary of
State so there is like a finite cost in
this they should have an FN even though
probably would have said minimal or are
indeterminable so that's one reason not
to do it and apparently now you would
only be able to like sign hold and do
other leering activities within that
defined area where now you can do it
anywhere in the general vicinity of the
polling place as long as not within the
specified radius which is usually pretty
clearly designated by signs on either
side of the entrances to the poing place
so it's usually pretty easy to figure
out where you can electioneer and where
you can't
actually with my gun guns at the polling
place belill that was one of the
considerations behind I was trying to
craft it so that the gun owner
presumably he may or may not he or she
may not be aware that it's election day
but if they do wand near the polling
place they should be able to see the
signs they should also be able to see
the candidates and other individuals
standing 101 ft from the doors so that
should be a sign that they're just
trying to prevent them from wandering
you know into the uh polling place say
to find in that bill so I I so I think
the existing law existing law is pretty
clear on like where you can hold your
signs where you can try to talk to the
voters
although I don't know about rident
navalo I find the voters are usually
happy to talk usually happy to see the
candidates regardless of where they're
voting for them but I don't really know
if there's a whole lot of uh
debating substance of debating going on
I don't think that many people are that
many voters are making their decision
based on what the candidate says while
they're like like walking into the
polling place I think they've usually
decided who they're going to vote for
before they get out of the parking lot
and start walking to polling place I
might also add a lot of people like seem
to detour around us so they there's some
people just don't want to talk to us at
all so so I don't think that's really a
big part of it's something you should be
able to do it's part of the campaign I
don't think that's like a huge part of
the campaign so if you're relying on
like your conversations with the voters
at the polling place to convince them to
vote for you I think probably you
started your camp campaign a little bit
too late but um so that's uh I I'm
worried about you know just sort of
designating
a circumscribed area and then apparently
you can't election ear outside of that
and also I'm going to say that criminal
penalty that's a pretty excessive
criminal penalty and it seems to apply
not just as the moderator but like seem
to other people apparently we could he's
a very nice man I'd hate to like uh he
certainly doesn't deserve be prosecuted
apparently you could try to prosecute
the Secretary of State you or even a
candidate or whoever else so that's
criminal criminal penalty is pretty
excessive so I would I would say this
bill is unnecessary our polling our
polling places are uh re reasonably
orderly and I think it actually creates
less space for you to hold your signs
talk to the voters and do all the things
people like to do on Election Day so I
would say advis an itl that bill and um
so that's that's what I have to say and
you're done with me for the day so you
enjoy the rest of the afternoon without
me and if you want to take any if you
want to ask ask me any questions I can
try to answer them or questions from the
committee seeing none thank you uh next
up is Senator Tim
law thank Mr chairman nice to see you
all thanks for working on the vacation
week keeping such an aggressive schedule
my first appearance here in election law
I have some written testimony which I'll
hand in but I don't think I'll read it
um kind of a numbers guy so I'll just
talk to you a little bit about first of
all I'm Senator Tim MCU from marac I
represent District 11 marac Milford
amist and Wilton and I haven't been
through nearly as many elections as many
of you but after 10 elections over 29
years I've had the first six had one or
two polling places it varied a little
bit the next two had three polling
places and the next one had six over 14
hours so as you can see it kind of
varies a bit and at each one of those uh
well the
first nine had the same moderator at the
main polling
place and the story was always uh that's
always the way we've done things until
somebody came up and which was okay it
was nice to have a bit of consistency
but local knowledge and knowledge of the
the history books was everything until
you tried to have a bit of a creative
Twist on how things uh how you might
campaign or
electioneer um and then there was a need
for some rules to be set forth and to me
it never mattered what the specific
rules were as long as they were
communicated effectively in
advance stayed the same during the
campaign and the polling place and the
Ping place and were equally equally
enforced and that was often the problem
was that you know deciding on them and
and communicating them
until uh our moderator distributed a
schematic diagram so much to my surprise
in this bill there is a call for that um
I've read through and secretary scandin
knows we've had numerous discussions on
this topic over the last three or four
years um
I've read through the lengthy moderator
manual which is very very thorough and
excellent excellent guide for our
moderators who have an incredible amount
of power uh and an incredible amount of
responsibility and and in my opinion by
and large do an amazing job dealing with
Incredible you know very w a wide
variety of situations and I think that's
part of what makes it difficult to
legislate some of these requirements
because every polling place is different
and you pulling out hours are different
and you know Wilton Town Hall is Tiny
and marac has three polling places and
so you things are things are different
so moderators have to have sound
judgment and that's why they're elected
and they have to have the
flexibility but and here's the butt um
candidates like we heard we've heard in
tes mod and we all know uh candidates
come and go and there's 30 30% turnover
so there isn't always that local
knowledge you don't you don't always
know exactly what the rules are so the
ability to look at a schematic know
where you're supposed to stand how
you're allowed or not allowed to engage
a voter so you can plan in advance and
everybody has that Level Playing Field
would be tremendously helpful and fair
and frankly it's just common sense so if
if you know you can set up the day
before or you know you can't set up
until
5:59 a.m. when the polling place opens
at 6 fair is fair everybody's on a Level
Playing Field that's that's that's okay
that's perfectly fine so I think that's
what this bill attempts to do um and
there's a I'll call it a companion bill
it's Senate Bill 216 which I hope I'll
get a chance to present to you I've got
to make it through the other body first
but myself and six of my Senate
colleagues and a couple of house members
have co-sponsored that um so I will
suggest that you consider some of that
language as well uh it's the same same
topic um it doesn't include a schematic
but it does attempt to clarify two other
vague issues not only um but it has it
has to do with the electioneering
Corridor specifically how far does it
extend and when does control of that
Corridor start there's two bit of two
bits of vague language one is what is
prior to um is it in fact does this
start now you know we have a couple of
elections coming up so does the
moderator control it now I mean it is
prior
to so um or or is it midnight the night
before or is it one minute
before and what all what
defines ATT what defines attending your
constitutionally
protected Free Speech or your political
communication so in statute we defined
we Define political speech or
communication you know uh what I'm
getting at is a sign a yard sign we've
all I know you've heard this discussion
about holding a sign or a totem or a
sign on a stick or a sign printed on a
tent I could relate to you um some of
the evolving rules that we had uh when I
think I might have been the first in
1998 to purchase one of those easy up
tents from Sam's Club and put it and
then we had a rule about whether you
could or couldn't have tents and then
tents became fashionable then we had a
tent
Lottery we literally had a tent Lottery
and that worked out fairly well then we
got rid of the tent Lottery then we had
a draw you know we had a drawing but the
most successful I think our candidates
will tell you the most successful four
elections were those where we everybody
knew where they had to be and when they
could be there that was just fair you
could plan um and it didn't change but
anyhow uh back to the the attending of
signs so you have a nice sign here thank
you for putting that up I was able to uh
sit across the street and know exactly
what Billy were on so I really
appreciate that but I'll ask you am I
now I'm not oh so in the opinion of the
chair I'm currently not attending this
sign because I'm not touching it so now
I'm attending it now I'm attending it
that's interesting so but in the opinion
of some moderators I am absolutely
attending this sign because I'm six feet
away um but representative kosovski
would not be attending the sign because
he's too far away you get the idea how
far is too far like and that's that's
the the difference in in every case at
the six polling places during my last
election I would absolutely be attending
that sign I did not have to be
physically touching it but I know of at
least a half a dozen polling places from
uh House and Senate colleagues where you
have to be physically touching the sign
or you have to lay it down and put it
put it down and that's the variance so
the other bill that I mentioned attempts
to Define attending uh attendance of a
sign and the prior to the those two bits
of of vagueness um again don't care what
the outcome is just care that it is
defined and that it's communicated and
equally enforced for all parties
involved and keeps the field level so
those are the things um that I had to
say a lot of other states have done this
by the way I did do a little bit of
research Montana does it uh
Massachusetts does it uh let's see uh
Arizona Indiana they all have language
similar to this I'm not saying we should
copycat um you know we are we are do
like to be different but I think uh the
most important thing is just designate a
safe space for candidates and voters to
interact equally and safely and
everybody knows the rules um and
hopefully I'll see you again and I'd
love to take questions and and talk to
you about any of those things that I
talked about if you want to know about
tent lotteries um I will say our our new
moderator uh Brian McCarthy if you're
listening he did chalk Mark I'm glad it
didn't rain night but we had some chalk
marks the night before that election was
absolutely as smooth as it could have
gone everybody knew when you could be
there where you could be there exactly
where you could park your car place your
tent and it worked so we and this this
and and the diagrams were published too
where you could park they were emailed
out to everybody but post on a website
would be even better because there is a
challenge getting uh emails of a
candidate especially a new candidate or
a candidate's design or representative
sometimes those emails just went to the
uh the party chair and there's often
discussion about you know did it make it
then to the specific candidate on the
ballot so on a website or publicly
available I think would be even better
on the uh Secretary of State's website
would be even better I know that would
be a big burden probably so um happy to
take any questions on on this subject
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you next last up is
good afternoon my name is Sarah Burke
Cohen I represent the New Hampshire
Municipal
Association the New Hampshire Municipal
Association opposes this bill um it
requires a schematic to be submitted um
well in advance of the election day um
the nhma sees us as problematic because
it takes away the moderator's ability to
adjust the area uh based on weather
obviously we can see that how that could
happen this year with all the snow out
there traffic patterns and other
conditions on Election Day That Could
impact what the space looks like um it
also uh requires the area to be marked
physically but it doesn't indicate in
this bill when that should happen is
that when the schematic is submitted is
that um on Election Day Before election
day some of these um polling places are
schools so it could be problematic if
you're putting out chalk or um if you're
putting out uh you know wooden Stakes to
Mark something off it could be
problematic if you do do it well in
advance to um from election day um so in
some this bill raises practical issues
that will make implementation burdensome
for municipalities um and we urge you to
itl this bill um open to questions other
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you um I
don't have any more pink cards uh there
was no one on the blue sheet signed up
that did not speak and online it was uh
three support 20 opposed one neutral
with that we will close the public
hearing on House Bill 333 and open up
the public hearing on House Bill 395
recognize representative Pam Brown um
for the purpose of introduction
law R Brown is that written testimony
okay can you put that on the desk we
don't we don't distribute it because we
get so much of it uh we we collect it at
the end of the day and it keeps
you all right welcome to election law
yeah good
afternoon Ed funding's downstairs
working hard too so lucky
yes um so thank you for um hearing my
testimony I um have served as a pole
worker and I've also done election um
challenging in
Manchester election Integrity is
important for my constituents um I know
your committee is addressing things like
machinery and vote voter IDs and same
day registration but the supervisor of
the checklist I think need need greater
oversight so I decided to draft a bill
the bill simply amends RSA 658 Co 2 to
give the inspectors of Elections the
power to observe all activities and
documents handled by the supervisors of
checklists in a town or Ward for those
unaware inspectors of elections are pole
workers and observers who are appointed
by our two major political parties for
two-year terms to assist with and
monitor election
activities the supervisors of the
checklist wield significant power over
over voter registration and election
Integrity their duties include
maintaining current voter databases
meeting regularly for checklist
maintenance and attending elections
including School District elections and
other meetings where checklists are used
such as
deliberatively um the entire checklist
every 10 years and sending notices by
mail to the last known addresses of
those to be removed removing voter names
after receiving change of address
reports from the postal service
department of safety or Secretary of
State removing voter names after
receiving notices through the Statewide
database that a voter has registered in
another state removing voter names after
receiving death notices from the clerk's
office approving new voters after examin
examining documents confirming age
citizenship and domicile approving
uniformed and overseas citizen absentee
voting
applications uh you get the idea issuing
guidelines and also most importantly
promptly reporting to the Secretary of
State and attorney general any evidence
of voter fraud when it arises and later
initiating removal of those persons from
the checklist by sending notices
so to me the check the supervisors of
the checklist are where the rubber meets
the road when it comes to election
integrity and my bill simply offers a
few more sets of pairs of eyes to as a
check and a balance on their activities
to me this is important because
um it's often a a select board uh or a
supervisor's board may be composed
entirely of individuals belonging to one
political party
and RSA 654 allows that quote all
decisions of the supervisors of the
checklist shall be made by a majority
vote
thereof rather than make the supervisors
um a partisan office which I had
considered initially uh in I decided
giving inspectors of Elections increased
oversight seemed the easiest solution I
noticed RSA 669 col 7 States no
inspector of election shall at the same
time serve as a supervisor of the
checklist
the second change you're going to see um
is that my bill amends RSA 669 col
64 it authorizes the town moderator
rather than the remaining supervisors
quote unquote to fill seats on the Su on
the supervisor's board should they
become
vacant and a final change was added
requiring that an appointed
supervisor um come from the same
political party if known if as the super
supervisor vacating a position and I
added this in to ensure that the
political makeup the of the supervisors
previously elected by voters was not
influenced or
62 states that a town moderator vacancy
a town moderator vacancy shall be filled
by appoint By Appointment made by the
supervisors of the
checklist um um so a potential issue
because I did spend my week reading
through the election laws in our
RCS so a potential had a fun week
yeah a potential issue for this bill
might appear to be that the checklist
information handled by the supervisors
includes public and non-public
information and RSA 6 5431 describes the
non-public checklist as the checklist
bearing names of Voters who by law are
entitled to have their status as a voter
kept non-public for reasons such as
protective
orders and RSA 654 31 describes a right
to know exemption which states only
public information is subject to right
to know when it comes to voter
information all other information shall
be treated as confidential information
and exempt from public
disclosure however I read further in
this particular RSA and it states
election officials and law enforcement
in furtherance of their official duties
May access and may disclose information
from the voter registration forms
affidavits religious exemptions and
other information necessary to resolve a
challenge to an individual registering
to vote or if or voting if necessary to
investigate and prosecute election law
violations so there is a role for
non-public information if you're an
elected
official and that's all I have I'd be
happy to answer any
questions other questions from the
committee yeah go ahead representative
Ward thank you and thank you for taking
my question I wonder if you'd indulge me
in describe what you see going on on
Election Day as described in lines 19
through
21 how are these inspectors going to see
the documents and if there's two
inspectors and there's six or seven
people signing up new registrant how are
they going to they're going to stop and
look at every
document
well the idea is that the inspectors of
Elections would attend meetings of the
supervisors during the year when they're
registering new new voters looking at
documentation to verify ID domicile and
citizenship so that would be something
that they could do um they don't have to
do that but it's an option that they
Avail that would be available to them
and they also do work on Election Day
the inspectors are the two of them at
least are pole workers others can be
appointed as well but at least two
become pole workers what do you follow
what do you mean by pole worker um
inspectors of elections are appointed by
political parties and two are appointed
to each um polling
place two of them become regular poll
workers they're sworn in and they they
do they do regular poll
work like hand out follow hand out
ballots
yes further questions representative
Newsome thank you um the amendment in
line the part in 27 and 28 that um says
if a town elects supervisors by means of
partisan ballot it would be so you're
removing that part so isn't that making
a what would be a
nonpartisan position into a partisan an
appointment when the towns have already
made the conscious decision not to have
partisan
supervisors I think that the way I've
written drafted this um it would include
either partisan or nonpartisan towns
elections for this position for the
supervisor's
position yeah oh thank you but in a town
that has
nonpartisan why would then all of a
sudden it would have to be a partisan
replacement that's a good question I was
just trying to maintain the the
political makeup of the supervisors
static and
unchanging um but I'd be happy to it's
your bill now but I'd be happy to
entertain an amendment to strike that
section I was just trying to um allow
for um a supervisor who's been elected
say as a Republican and there are two
Democrats to continue to have a
particular um supervisor appointed who
is from the same political party as the
person who's being replaced but that was
just something I thought about adding I
it's not something I would it's not a
on further questions um my only question
is and you I'm glad you brought it up in
your testimony which is these uh
protected names on the checklist you
know you mentioned RSA 3 654 31 you know
25 has the same language in it um the
name and address of voter shall not
appear on checklist at the request of a
voter if a voter presents supervisor of
the checklist with the valid protective
order um you not see an issue with
people who've never been through the
scrutiny of an election having access to
these this basically this this
orders well I'm thinking the inspectors
would be there not actively voting or
taking part in the activities of the
supervisors but just being observers
okay um any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you thank you so much I only have one
other card um Sarah Brook Cohen from the
New Hampshire Municipal Association um
representative gusovsky if you grab me
sheet good afternoon my name is Sarah
Burke Cohen I represent the Hampshire
Municipal Association the New Hampshire
Municipal Association opposes this bill
um I think the committee has brought up
a number of the issues that we see with
it um the inspectors
um as stated in this bill would uh be
allowed access to personally
identifiable information of Voters and
they are not authorized uh people to be
doing that including 173b which is on
the um non-public 17 B 173b restraining
order
um indications that are on the
non-public list um with regard to the
appointment of the um supervisors of the
checklist um my understanding is
Portsmith is the only um partisan El
electing City in the state and town um
so the language um in six the new
language in
66964 um to go on what representative
Newsome would be problematic given that
you would be uh essentially making a
partisan position from a nonpartisan
position in municipalities that have
elected to stay
nonpartisan
um in addition um it's not uh a regular
activity for the moderator to be
appointing um people to positions um I
believe the only position that's
appointed by a moderator if it's vacant
is on uh a municipal budget committee um
it having talked to some of the
supervisors of the checklist their
thought process is the moderator doesn't
often have an understand true
understanding of what the supervisors of
the checklists um have to do and that is
why it is in the hands of the others on
the supervisors of the checklist uh
board to um fill the fill that vacancy
um with that said um as I said nhma uh W
opposes this bill in uh would like you
to itl it questions are there questions
Gore does has the municipal Association
ever had
any interaction
with ter here um inspectors of
election I mean I've been a moderator or
supervisor checklist 20 years and uh
I've never come across before so this is
a new thing to
me you've never had an inspector at your
poll I've I've had the AG's office show
up okay I mean that's
normal I don't actually work a polling
site um but um my understanding is with
what the um the appointment and
Authority that is in this bill would
allow inspectors to be appointed by
their political party and have access to
voter information right they they are
I'm just saying that's what that's
that's what I see too and I've just
never experienced that I mean I do have
the AG show up for five minutes and but
that's you know that's just part of the
routine that's not our understanding is
inspectors are are allowed to and do go
to polling sit
well maybe not yours I thank you yeah
okay further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um I
don't have any other cards there was
Zero people on the blue sheet there was
two in support no again against and
online there was four in support 58
against one neutral with that I will
close the public hearing for House Bill
395 and open the public hearing for
House Bill 409 uh 409 was withdrawn by
the sponsor um the sponsor was a
Democrat so for the first time today
representative Gilmore can you go and
introduce House Bill 409 by title only
and take no questions for this withdrawn
bill um because that's what I do if it's
a republican Prime sponsored Bill a
republican goes if it's a Democrat a
Democrat goes I'm fair I'm Fair um for
what I'm hoping is the world's shortest
Bill and uh thank you Mr chair and I
have the honor of introducing House Bill
409 relative to fee structures for
election recounts and
um proceed and uh no I don't need to
take any questions thank you that's
awesome I was worried for a second like
you were gonna consider it like oh what
have I
done uh representative Gilmore just just
so you know just that you're you're
representative Gilmore and you represent
do right all right good okay uh I have
no pink cards for 409 would anyone else
like to speak on house 409 seeing none
we're going to close the public hearing
on houseb 409 um there online there was
forign support 5 oppos two neutral
represented gasi is that blue sheet
blank and there was one on one against
the withdraw bill on the blue sheet with
that we'll close the public hearing on
House Bill 49 the committee will stay in
recess until 3:10 for the introduction
e
okay okay all right uh we we did 409
great hearing all right going to open up
the public hearing for House Bill 521
authorizing online voter registration
representative Paige yeah there you are
say I knew it's your bill I don't did
you fill out a card for us yet
representative awesome
um no problem we don't have too many
cards for this I thought thought there
would have been
more I gave this one extra time I think
didn't I no I scheduled it before
the all right Paige welcome back to
election law you were here you were our
very first bill actually oh thank you
and not your last so thank you I guess I
get points for showing up um this is my
for the record I'm Mark page I represent
the town of exiter Rockingham 11 and um
this bill is a bill that would create
online voter registration pretty
straightforward um I think heard a lot
of feedback from the last election about
uh length of lines um I heard from a
number of folks too who were new to my
town but um not new to New Hampshire
about registering to vote uh and
repeating that process this bill would
address that as well
So Not only would it um expedite the
process for registering to vote but it
would expedite the process for folks who
move within New Hampshire from a ward or
from a different neighboring town which
happens uh quite frequently um this
would if we were to pass this uh we
would be the 43rd state to do it so it's
been modeled and done with some Success
New Hampshire rightfully uh you know can
take their time to make sure we don't
make any mistakes that other states have
done but I think now at this point with
42 States having success we can um
perhaps take some lessons from that um
the system would would um in essence you
know be only available for folks with
New Hampshire um IDs and it would allow
the um registrations to process only if
uh the verification of through the DMV
of age citizenship all the requirements
um for for registering vote the bill
does not make any changes to the
requirements of voting to of registering
to vote in fact it's a bit dynamic
because the language in it would just
whatever the requirements are uh would
continue along um just the registration
system allows for an online
option um election ficials still at the
local level supervisors of the checklist
still uh would have uh be at the core of
the process because they would be the
applications would be submitted to them
uh and for their determination of uh
putting them on the on the RO s in
addition uh signature would be required
for the first vote for the when a first
when a person first shows up to vote for
the first time they would be required to
uh present their signature uh and as
well to request an absentee
ballot
um they would have to uh do that as well
so that's that's in essence what it is
there folks behind me that can probably
speak to more of the technical
aspects uh of the bill I think it helps
capture some efficiencies a lot of this
information exists over at the DMV U my
understanding is the Secretary of
State's office is uh in the midst of um
creating rfps or redeveloping their
voter registration database this would
kind of work in concert with that so
this is potential to capture
um yeah happy to answer
questions okay are there questions from
the
oh all right fire a couple people who
wants to go first right representative
wood thank you taking my question um is
this going to be used in conjunction
with other databases in the town in the
state you mentioned the
DMV well the the information from the
DMV would be um used uh to verif as
verified through that with in
conjunction with the state uh Secretary
of State's voter registration database
so uh the information and other folks
can te speak more to the technical side
of things but that that would be the
first step at the DMV where they're
personally you know checking your
information and logging it in their
database but if if they if that was
inconsistent with the requirements of
the election law then then that that
would not proceed the registration
wouldn't proceed but it would be
transmitted through um sharing that
information with this to the Secretary
of State's office
yeah
follow thank you um you mentioned
signature is does the signature have to
be done in person how's the signature
going to be collected they need to
provide a signature so if we go online
get this going you still have to go in
and sign so your first electronic
signature would start the process going
electronic and then your signature
before you would vote first you still
have to present with a signature for
your first
ballot further questions from the
I guess I have a question about we've
we've got before us numerous bills about
citizenship
requirements to my knowledge there's
nothing in New Hampshire or even at the
federal level that would allow you to
verify citizenship through a database is
that your understanding as well that
there's nothing I believe so yes so what
would someone do here
to prove citizenship under
this so I I think through the DMV
process if you were going through a real
ID process the documents that you could
present would be a pass a birth
certificate things that would be would
would speak to citizenship and that
would be on file with the DMV if I'm
understanding your question
correctly followup yeah I'll save it for
the folks behind thanks okay okay I
mean any other questions from the
committee seeing done thank you next up
is Julian I'm having trouble reading it
I apologize I'm having trouble reading
Julianne press that silver
button thank you chairman Barry and uh
members of the House election law
committee my name is Julian
Gori I am a busy working parent of two
teenagers and I live in conquer I serve
as the executive director of 603 forward
and the forward Foundation which are two
nonpartisan
organizations dedicated to educating
activating and empowering people in New
Hampshire under age 50 to be civically
engaged I'm here to test ify in support
of House Bill 521 which would establish
an online voter registration system in
New Hampshire this legislation is common
sense it would modernize our elections
save taxpayer money make voter
registration more accessible and
increase
efficiency this bill reflects the
reality of the lives of busy Granite
Staters I myself am a busy working
parent I've moved numerous times to
different towns in New Hampshire I've
owned homes in Bristol and
conquered when I got married I changed
my last name I've often had a commute to
both bring my kids to school and to work
and I worked during regular business
hours and during all of those times I
had to take time off of work to go to
the town clerk to update my voter
registration imagine all of the people
in New Hampshire who don't have the
ability and the time to take to take off
work and might just give up and not
vote it would have been a lot easier if
I could have just updated my
registration
online and this online voter
registration has proven to be more
secure and less costly in 42 States
across the
country currently when someone goes to
their town clerk to register or update
their registration the election
officials have to manually type voter
registrations and updates into the
online system if this were a business we
would say no in a heartbeat and
modernize the
process online voter registration has
been proven to be more secure reduce
time be more cost effective and allow
busy people with all kinds of things in
their lives going on to still update
their registrations and vote for many
working AG young Granite Staters with
irregular schedules limited
Transportation disabilities or just
making that extra trip trip during lunch
hour or at the end of their working day
can be a significant barrier to
registration by allowing voters to
safely and easily access this online
registration portal House Bill 521 would
encourage more people to register before
election day reducing the long lines of
over two hours we saw in some places
this past
election reduce confusion at the polls
and reduce the need for affidavits
New Hampshire is only one of eight
states that has not yet implemented
online voter
registration this would ensure that
we're keeping Pace with modern ele
election processes while maintaining
integrity and local
control voters would verify their
identity using driver's license or non-d
driver's ID as we just heard and which
still adds the layer of security to
registration process and this still
allows for uh the identification things
that need to be proved it doesn't change
that all online registrations would
still need to be reviewed by the local
election official before being added to
the
checklist this legislation is not just
good for voters it also benefits our
election
officials entering registration
information online reduces manual data
entry errors and saves time for election
workers who currently must process paper
forms by
hand research has shown that online
voter registration is also significantly
more cost effective than paper
registration saving taxpayer
dollars currently we can pay our bills
online we can register our vehicles we
can Bank we can apply for update our
driver's license it's time that we allow
voters to update their
registration in House Bill 521 would
bring us into this modern era I
encourage you to V please vote a to pass
on
521 will you be taking questions from
the
committee yes are there questions from
committee saying none thank you next up
is Liz tantarelli on Deck will be Kaylee
esto and then after that McKenzie Taylor
for the record my name is Liz tentarelli
I'm uh testifying today on behalf of the
League of Women Voters of New Hampshire
who support this bill as one step in
necessary modern ization of our election
system I do want to emphasize that this
still leaves the supervisors of the
checklist in charge of the
registration they will see the material
that's been submitted online they can
check it against State sources and local
sources so any attempt to try to trick
those supervisors of the checklist would
likely be
thwarted and um the previous speaker hit
some of my other points except for the
handwriting issue when people fill out a
handwritten voter registration often
their handwriting looks like my
grandson's handwriting he's a grown-up
but his handwriting is terrible and when
things are done online which he does
very well it's much more likely to be
accurate so that's all I have to add to
the testimony that was already given
thank you for the opportunity if there
are questions I'd be happy to answer
them
further questions other questions from
the committee thank you seeing none
estadio thank you chairman Barry and
members of the House election law
committee for the record my name is Kaye
of stadio I'm a Durham voter and public
policy fellow with open democracy and
I'm testifying today in support of HB
521 um members of the special committee
on voter confidence in 2022 spent 37
hours listening to election workers and
other vital stakeholders as they shared
what they felt would create higher
levels of confidence in our elections
many felt that just a simple
modernization in the form of creating an
online voter registration portal would
help create more secure and accessible
voting one of the worst things on
Election Day is when someone says they
are registered to vote that they have
voted at this ping location before but
they are not on the checklist you check
with the supervisor who then located
their voter registration paperwork only
to find that the individual is on the
checklist but their name is spelled
incorrectly the second letter of their
last name is spelled with an O instead
of an A or any sort of
combination the voter was incorrectly
entered into the database because the
superviser of the checklist couldn't
read their handwriting and who can blame
them establishing an online voter
registration portal has the potential to
save New Hampshire millions of dollars
each election by replacing costly paper
based registration forms even without
the cost of postage and printing
research shows that the pro that
processing a paper voter registration
application costs approximately
$4.72 in staff time if the Senate is
able to save local taxpayers money this
is just a win-win online voter portal
systems are also affordable to set up
one idea to strengthen this bill will be
to clarify the election procedure manual
for allowing a voter to sign the form
with a digital signature if we can sign
highly important and confidential Bank
docu documents with digital signatures
we should be able to do the same when it
comes to
voting um I recommend removing the
reference to wet signatures from the
election law procedure manual please
side with the voters by assisting in the
inevitable modernization of New
Hampshire's voter registration system by
voting a to pass on HB 521 thank you and
I'll take questions if there are any
other questions can you send us that
$421 statistic yes I can um because that
actually those things are always very
interesting to me yeah um next last up
Taylor good afternoon chairman members
of the committee my name is McKenzie
Taylor um and I'm with New Hampshire
campaign for voting rights and America
votes um and I'm here today in support
of house Bell 521 um this is a more
secure way to allow voters to register
or update their registration um ahead of
election day while still keeping the
security and checks of the election
officials in our process uh I was one of
the voters who waited about 45 minutes
in line just to update my registration
update my name on Election Day the
person next to me thought he was
registered had to wait in line and then
wait in line to register um and this is
a way to for some voters that meet the
qualifications be able to register ahead
of election day reduce those lines and
reduce the number of folks who have to
start and complete the whole process on
election day especially during these
busy elections um or when they don't
vote for 2 years and their registration
is inaccurate for that amount of time um
wanted to talk a little bit through
because I think there's just some
clarification with how this bill is more
specific this year than it's been in the
past how this would work um so this
system would only be for voters who have
either New Hampshire license or New
Hampshire non voter ID um in other
states people actually start this
process by putting in their license or
ID number so it connects directly to
their profile um and make sure that they
are the person they say they are uh then
if the person had it would verify that
their address on their license or with
the DMV is the same as the address
they're trying to register with it would
then be required and this is would work
for some people and not for some people
they would still have to register in
person because of the requirements of
proving citizenship it would then PLL
and see if in those State databases
there was proof of citizenship so for
example when I got my real ID I brought
in my passport therefore with the DMV my
proof of citizenship is on file if it
could do that you would be it would pull
your signature from your license you
would be registered but need to Reg to
fill out your signature in person at
some point before you cast that ballot
if uh either you didn't have a license
if you were registering a new license or
a new address but that address was not
on your license if you didn't have proof
of citizenship on file with the DMV for
some reason you would get an email it
says in this um in the bill that says
you're we weren't able to process your
online voter registration here are the
other ways you can register so go to
your clerk's office register on Election
Day that way so it this ises not
necessarily apply for everyone we know
that not everyone has a New Hampshire
license not everyone has used their
proof of citizenship to get that but it
is one more way to be able to have more
folks register ahead of time um which is
an important part of the process be able
to cut back on those really long lines
that we're seeing because so many people
are participating um and to still be
able to make sure ahead of time people
are also you know meeting all of those
criteria and probably in an easier way
if they showed their passport once when
they got their license um then they have
it on file and they don't necessarily
need to bring three or four documents
with them in person um and to be able to
have those either registrations started
or again updated like if you're updating
your name it's connected to your license
um ahead of time on through the system
so I am happy to answer any questions
especially about um the time or kind of
the process there or anything else other
questions from the committee
representative Lane um thank you thanks
for taking my question
so previously on another bill uh
Secretary of State indicated um that
they have uh access and the archives to
anyone who was born in New Hampshire so
that would prove citizenship
so does this bill would that when and I
know it talks about
DMV and I haven't read it word for as
carefully maybe as I should have but
enable whoever the supervisor whoever to
get into those records because anyone
and I think he said it was about a third
of New Hampshire's voters so about a
third of the voters would at least be
able to get past the citizenship proof
issue wouldn't help the rest of us who
weren't born here but so is that your
understanding or have you talked about
that or is that something that might be
feasible thanks for that question um I
had not necessarily heard exactly that
they had access to that in the bill as
it's written right now it says um if
they can be rectifi verified by the
records of the Department of State or
division of M vehicles um but if that
added in also the state database for
birth certificates or who was born there
you know that might allow folks who have
a license but didn't bring their birth
certificate because they brought their
social security card or something else
um to verify that way okay as well all
right seems like it's possible further
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you I don't have any other pink
cards on the blue sheet there was three
in support uh no opposed that signed up
and didn't
speak um and online it's actually
probably our most highly contested Bill
support 456 oppose 2370 neutral with
that we will close the public hearing
for House Bill 521 and we will start our
last public hearing 2 minutes behind
schedule with 16
bills and I'm gonna have to have
representative toner introduce
it toner can you please introduce 220
for
us which I only have one pink card on
just say they should just let me
schedule all the bills just for the
houses I'm representative toner um I'm
from bnat 4 which represents Belmont I'd
like to introduce House Bill 220 FN and
I will not take any questions excellent
you get to close us out so oh my God
it's lot shoot some fireworks or
something I don't know okay um thank you
chairman Barry members of the House
election law committee for the record
again my name is kayy of stadio I'm a
Durham voter and public policy fellow
with open
democracy and I'm testifying today in
opposition to
hb220 in a state where independent
voters make up nearly 40 % of the
electorate passing hb220 would blatantly
disenfranchise countless Undeclared Gran
stators who take great pride in voting
despite not being as radical as their
partisan counterparts additionally New
Hampshire taxpayers currently subsidize
political party candidate selection for
the two major parties re restricting
Undeclared voters from primaries would
only work to further ostracize and
penalize these voters who themselves are
the ones funding the elections primaries
are also often the most consequential
elections this meant that in 2022
because 85% of congressional districts
enclosed primary states were considered
safe most independent voters were
effectively left without any real voice
at The Ballot Box during the general
election according to the United America
Institute 48% of Independents say they
truly do not lean towards one party over
another 26% were previously Democrats
and 27% were previously
Republicans the levels of malicious
crossover voting are also not
significant enough to Warrant silencing
such a massive portion of constituents
as chairman Barry duly noted last
Tuesday when discussing HB 172 which
would have restricted Undeclared voters
from same day voting in presidential or
state primaries even the most concerted
efforts of bad faith actors on the left
during last year's presidential
primaries resulted in little impact on
the Republican nominee ejecting all
Undeclared voters from the primary would
essentially be forfeiting 80% of votes
casting good faith to go to go after the
20% that could be considered to have
been cast in bad faith for these reasons
I urge you to vote hb220 in expedient to
legislate and ensure New Hampshire
continues to provide representations to
all of its voters thank you and I'll
take questions if there are any are
there any questions from the
Committee hearing none thank you we did
thank you I'm also speaking in
opposition to hb220 FN I think the
previous speaker covered it pretty well
I just wanted to point out also that uh
parties actually usually want to have
independent voters vote it actually
helps them it helps them helps
independent helps them keep their power
to be quite honest with you so if you
decide to close these primaries whether
I've said previously in other testimony
that it's actually unconstitutional for
the state to close the primaries against
the party's wishes if the parties want
you to close them then at the moment
it's it's allowed but you're wake you
would be waking up a a sleeping giant
because independent voters outnumber the
Republicans and the Democrats in the
state and they're kind of uh sleeping
right now because they feel like they
get to participate in the process
process but if they're cut out of a
process that's being sponsored and
funded by the state and they don't get a
say even though it's the preliminary
step in a general election which are
public elections I I can I can bet you
that you're going to have uh a big
movement of independent voters so we'll
see what happens I hope you oppose this
bill because we do want to have a say
and if somehow this bill passes well
we'll get busy that's all I have to say
thank you okay well you be making
questions yes if you have any are there
questions representative
Gilmore don't you think this might
impact New Hampshire's presidential
primary if it were to keep independence
from voting in
it yes uh a big part of the New
Hampshire presidential primary is that
everyone's interested in in what what
the independent voters are going to do
and it's what's one of the big the big
parts of this being a a good place for
the first of the nation primary
because it it's one of the states with
the highest number of independent voters
and we're known as being a very
independent state so if if the
independent voters don't have a say
we're not going to have any voice as
being such a small state as we are thank
you further questions from the committee
saying none thank you um I don't have
anyone else other know the pink cards um
on the blue sheet was zero in support
four against and
online was pretty lopsided 11 in support
340 opposed zero neutral with that we
close the public hearing House Bill 220
that concludes our public hearings for
the day uh I do need reports from last
week I don't think I saw them come
through um from anyone just to be fair
like it's not that's not a condemnation
of either side like I didn't see any
them come
through yeah but but I do need them uh
tonight from the ones from last week so
that I can put them on or try to put
I'm going to make the deadline so um
anyway so if you owe reports please do
that otherwise uh I will Author them and
who knows you know maybe maybe I do a
good job maybe I don't who knows so
could I just a point of order um many of
four of these bills that we heard today
are ones that we don't often hear yes
about so keep talking the mic just a
little more is there is there a way and
our poor researcher in the back there
but
um that we could get more information
whether it's research or more
information about CU I'm just not
familiar enough with these processes to
make an intelligent
decision I mean if you have a specific
question I'm happy to I haven't denied
anything to the researcher yet from a
request from a member so if you have a
specific question I just I guess I I
don't know what to ask of the researcher
I'm stumbling because I can't either
yeah um if you have something send to me
I haven't denied anything um I I think I
actually made my first request request
of the researcher today um my my first
so um you know if if you have anything
you know I I I haven't turned anything
down I reserved the right to turn
something down if it's you know
unreasonable but I haven't seen anything
yet been requested that I think even
approached something that was
unreasonable okay um so I guess is that
the best way to answer the question okay
I'll try and articulate it better next
time yeah sort of and I I no one took my
vote for the rank Choice voting
but and I I and you know I'm I'm excited
I want you to see what regular ballots
in New Hampshire look like so good luck
good luck
um
go go for uh so uh we will be meeting
next Tuesday there will be votes next
Tuesday I think we have like seven
hearings left um the committee assistant
is getting me the list just so that her
and I are on the same page um but I I'm
thinking that going forward our our
committee days will look more like
regular committees do and not
the uh go go go go go so um with that
we'll be I'll see you next Tuesday I
won't see you on Thursday um and yeah